this is jocko podcast number 250
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
so on the last podcast number 249 we
were reading
the newest edition of the book about
face by colonel david hackworth which
has a written
forward in it written by me and if you
haven't listened to 249 yet
just go back right now and listen to
that one first
and we ended up reading some of the book
but we just started to scratch the
surface
and and look i i was prepping for this
podcast and saying you know what we
should read
a little bit more
read a little bit more from the book
talk about it a little bit more
and just as things start to pick up in
the korean war we just start to learn
these incredible lessons
so we're going to take one more look at
about face today
picking up it actually picks up you know
that when you write a book
they they want you to have like the big
action scene in the beginning
i did not know that but i i understand
right right so they want you know
the reader to not you know to pick up
the book and invest something into the
book
so this book starts off with a big time
action scene that we actually read last
time
so this is a later chapter but it
actually predates the big action scene
of february 6 which is this
battle where he gets wounded and you get
shot in the head david hackworth gets
shot in the head
and all this mayhem happens so
this is actually predates that with him
kind of showing up in korea and so
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
talk through some of these things i'm
going to try and
slow it down and talk about some of the
things that i pull out of this book
so here we go back to the book
the course of the korean war had changed
dramatically since its lightning fast
beginning
at the start u.s forces hopelessly
outnumbered
out gunned and under-trained had been
driven back by the north koreans into
the tiniest corner of south korea
beyond the naktong river
there the eighth army dug in its heels
determinedly
holding what was known as the busan
perimeter until september when
macarthur's daring amphibious
invasion at inchon severed the north
korean army's lines of communications
and chopped its legs out from under it
no longer was the enemy ineffective
fighting force and our certain defeat
along the lines of dunkirk in 1940
suddenly appeared to be
sure-fire victory units of the eighth
army smashed out of naktong perimeter
spirits were high as we raced north
beyond the 38th parallel
beyond the north korean capital of
pyongyang to within spitting distance of
the yao lu river
the dividing line between north korea
and manchuria
fighting was sporadic but as units moved
further north the weather worsened
and enemy resistance increased it was
like a it was like compressing a
spring the night the chinese came
i was in a foxhole in the center of my
scout section's defensive position
now let's think about that the night the
chinese came
that's a scary thing and you know every
time i read about the korean war
which we've covered several korean war
memoirs on this podcast what a
what a savage scenario that was
and it's called the forgotten war
[Music]
and i did that piece uh i did a piece on
memorial day and talked about the
forgotten war and
and just about how anyone that was there
could never forget what those guys went
through in any way and if you pay any
attention to it whatsoever
you realize that we should always
remember
what sacrifices were made in the korean
war
and a lot of it this sentence right here
the night the chinese came
so here we go the night the chinese came
i was in a foxhole in the center of my
scout section's defensive position
the sector was densely covered with
screw pines and scrub oaks
my foxhole buddy and i were sitting on
the edges of our hole
when we saw and it was like right out of
a cartoon
a row of small trees moving toward us
we chopped them down along with a little
[ __ ]
creeping along behind each one with hand
grenades but that was just
the beginning the next thing i saw
was what i could only describe as a wave
a
human wave of chinese crashing over us
for the next three hours they came
wall-to-wall chinamen many of whom
did not even have rifles only long
lances tipped with bayonets
others were armed with u.s thompson
submachine guns or russian drum fed
assault rifles for the main they were
sorry shots with no understanding of
basic infantry tactics but what the
chinese lacked in proficiency
they made up for in numbers and their
presence heralded
the start of the largest and most bitter
retreat in us
army history so that's crazy
right you've got these these chinese
coming and they've got spears
and can you imagine imagine people
coming at you
for 10 minutes right like can you
imagine enough people that they can come
at you for 10 minutes
now imagine 30 minutes and you that
imagine how many people that is
now imagine three hours of people coming
at you
upon my arrival in korea i'd been
assigned the 25th recon company as a
replacement scout section leader it was
an army mistake my military occupational
specialty was
infantry not armored recon
and it had upset me to no end because
25th recon guys were not eligible
for the cib regardless of how much
infantry combat they saw
so the cib is the combat infantryman
badge and that's what you get when
you're
in direct combat in the army and it's a
let's say that's like a serious mark of
pride in the army because that means
you've been in the [ __ ]
so you can see a little bit of ego
creeping out from david hackworth
because he's like what are you kidding
me
we're just recon and we're we are not
even eligible for getting the cib
this is garbage
continuing add to that macarthur's
brilliant stroke at inchon
the war had seemed over saved for the
victory parade
and i'd been sick that after all i'd
gone through to get here i'd missed the
guts of the whole damn show
this is just once again this is typical
be careful what you wish for
he's thinking after inchon americans had
such a leg up
that ah i missed it i missed the war
hadn't wanted to show up in another
occupation force so
in the army when he joined the army he
went to europe
and world war ii was over and so he
showed up there and he was just
you know get you know standing around
and starting
standing guard duty and stuff like that
they were training but whatever he
wasn't getting the combat that he wanted
so he's afraid when he shows up in in
korea oh they did this big move at
inchon
we're not going to get any combat
i hadn't wanted to end up in another
occupation force
still sergeant combat and that's the
nickname that he earned himself
even when there was no combat when he
was in europe but he was just so
fired up they called him sergeant combat
only in a new theater in my heart i'd
secretly wish the war would continue
long enough to let me get involved in at
least one good fight
my wish came true only too well my first
real fire fight
and this is good teeth it's always good
to hear this right
because there's such a huge amount of
difference between
your first fire fight and your next one
just like any any anything that we do
anything that you do as a human being
the
learning curve when you see something
for the first time is the steepest
learning curve you're gonna get
so it's always good to think about these
things my first real firefight had
occurred just before the chinese came
on a dull overcast day the scout section
had set up near a secondary road we
spotted a squad of north korean soldiers
weapons at sling arms coming out of the
tree line they were
good-looking troops but asleep at the
switch they didn't see us
it was an amazing sense of power i felt
ultimate power i suppose
just watching them come and holding that
weapon in my hands
we let them get within about 30 yards
before we cut loose
i dropped four guys point blank with my
m1
each dead with a six o'clock sight
picture in the chest
just like the good book said i felt no
guilt
few of us did i'd been trained too well
and besides the enemy had been utterly
dehumanized throughout my training they
aren't men
they're just gooks i thought
as the four enemy fell and a fierce
firefight began we'd knocked off the
point element
of a much larger enemy force and stirred
up a hornet's nest
okay note on gooks the term and this is
this is in the book
it's a it's an asterisk the term [ __ ] is
derived from the
korean word han [ __ ] which means korean
person
so i know that it's a insensitive term
it's in the book
what does six o'clock sight picture mean
just where he's lining up
his his weapon the sight on his weapon
six o'clock sight picture basically a
point of aim point of impact so he's
just aiming
um i guess like towards the bottom of
his
he's lining up the bottom of his sight
on their chest
so he's simply saying like i like
made good shots essentially like
everything lined up perfectly yeah
and like the good book says i'm sure
he's referring to you know
the army marksmanship manual which says
you know once you get this
you you set the six o'clock of your site
onto the point of impact you want to hit
and i'm i i could be wrong about this
because i'm not i'm not 100 sure but
it's something
meaning hey he took the good solid sight
picture that he's supposed to get
the one that he was taught boom hit him
in the chest
but here's what sketchy is these were
just the point element
there's a bunch of people behind him
following the lead of a lot of the older
veterans
earlier in the day i'd placed several
clips of
ammo on my rifle sling i liked the look
it was kind of john waynish and it
seemed to make sense a new clip only
seconds away but when i'd taken up my
prone firing position
the sling had flopped on the rain-soaked
ground now as the firefight got going i
grabbed for a clip only to discover that
it and the rest of them were clogged
with mud
bullets were flying and my brain stalled
out i vaguely remembered an old tale
about how well the m1
worked under any battlefield condition
quickly knocking off the bigger pieces
of muzz
mud i oozed the clip up into my rifle i
got one round off
the weapon jammed and for the next few
minutes i sat in the ditch field
stripping cleaning and reassembling the
thing while my first real combat
went on without me our field our
artillery fire
took the starch out of the north korean
advance and we were able to scoot ass
with no friendly casualties
other that is than sergeant combat's
bruised pride my first firefight had
been my first screw-up
i didn't know until much later that you
generally don't walk away from that one
what does that say be prepared so here
he is in his first fire fight
he's got the cool guy bandolier scenario
going on
with his wet with his weapon and his
mags and it doesn't work out well
that's why you got to rehearse things
how they're gonna actually be
you can't just do something for the
first time in combat and be like oh this
will be fine
no a few days later five of us had been
out on a reconnaissance patrol it had it
was a very black knight
saved for the us flares that hung eerily
over the battlefield
very quiet but for the occasional wine
of artillery fire and the odd burst of
an automatic weapon
we had moved about a mile into enemy
territory when we heard
motors leaving the patrol i crawled to a
mound near the edge of the road for a
first-hand look
look through the darkness silhouetted by
the artillery flares i could see four
enemy vehicles
a file of infantry was walking on each
side of the motor column
with more infantry walking in front they
were so close that i was sure the
vehicle's engines prevented them from
hearing my pounding heart
they passed by i was about to return to
the patrol
when i saw a lone north korean soldier
his weapon slung
tracing a telephone wire as he passed my
position
i parted his hero hair with a submachine
gun
magazine and dragged him back to the
patrol so he knocked this dude out
think about that like a massive patrol
goes by you find
one lone guy take a magazine out of your
gear hit him on the head with it knock
him out
and then drag him back to your patrol
daylight wasn't far off when we headed
home
progress was slow initially we had to
pack our
zonked out prize we later he awoke
stumbled along belligerently but at
least under his own steam
when we thought we had made it we
ran into a large enemy force moving down
the road in formation
they were jabbering excitedly and
dragging machine guns behind
them on squeaky wheels we were about six
yards from the road
i lay on top of the prisoner covered his
mouth with my hand
and pressed my trench knife hard against
his throat
i thought the cold steel would be enough
to convince him to be good
but it wasn't old habits die hard
he started squirming around my hand was
muffling his cries to his comrades
when he tried to bite it i had no choice
i slit his throat and lay there on top
of him
for what seemed like a bloody eternal
eternity
until the road was clear and we could
hot-foot it back to the u.s
lines there you go
welcome to combat yeah
i hadn't wanted to kill him i would have
rather the capture the guy a live
prisoner is worth a thousand dead
hombres but i was probably as scared as
he was
and in a millionth of a second i had to
decide and it was either him
or my patrol
you know when people talk about the
split seconds decisions you have to make
in combat there you go what am i gonna
do i'm
gonna i'm gonna kill this guy
killing that guy in one other incident
probably hammered home most that korea
was not some training maneuver
that i was really in war boots and all
the other occurred when we were digging
in on a small knob overlooking a main
north-south road
digging in was a task of a front-line
trooper performed at least once a day
when on the move
usually spent a time cursing your
commander for always choosing the
hardest ground in the town
and then moving the line just when you'd
finished your hole
some of us thought it was an army plot
to keep us in shape for myself
i'd rather have done a million push-ups
but on this particular occasion we'd
gotten some great dirt
it was soft and loose a breeze to dig
and i was about two feet down in no time
then my shovel hit something mushy
a few quick scrapes revealed an olive
drab green material
a few more uncovered a decaying corpse
of a man
with bright red hair and a 24th division
patch on his moldy
fatigue jacket the soldier's hands had
been tied behind him with communication
wire
and he'd been shot in the back of the
head
three more bodies were found by other
troopers
on our little knob all killed and buried
the same way
company was notified they said the men
had probably been killed at the
beginning of the war
that was when the 24th division had
fought along this road
we were instructed to dig out the dog
tags and provide
eight-digit grid coordinates where each
body was found
the atrocity did little for morale but a
lot for fighting spirit
there would be no love lost for an enemy
as savage as the north korean reds
so much for the korean police action i
and my friends thought
this was all out war with no quarter
given
yeah he talked about dehumanizing the
troops and i've talked about
dehumanizing the enemy
and that is something that absolutely
the military will try and do
and it's a very crazy fine line to walk
because as you dehumanize the enemy
you're also
possibly dehumanizing the civilians that
are in that area and so you have a very
sketchy scenario that can unfold
but they still have to do it to some
level because otherwise you've got
people the us military that in their
mind
you know it's a sin to kill or whatever
beliefs they have they don't want to do
it
and you're trying to convince them that
it's okay because these aren't even
people
they're not even humans that's
dehumanizing
and i've said before and this is the
type of thing that
makes it very clear you know i've said
that the
we didn't real in in iraq we didn't
really have to dehumanize the enemy
because the enemy dehumanized themselves
with the things that they did to the
local populace
torture murder rape
just complete and utter savagery
and that's the same thing that's
happening right here you know you're
finding americans
that have been bound and executed in the
back of the head and buried in shallow
graves
continuing on now that the chinese were
in the conflict the recon company's
mission was to provide a reconnaissance
screen
in front of the 25th infantry division's
withdrawal
in other words to delay deceive and
disorganize
the undeniable communist advance so the
chinese are coming now
they've got the numbers they've got the
masses they've got
america on its heels get the 25th id
tropic lightning by the way
stationed in hawaii i went out and i
went out and spoke had the honor of
speaking to the 25th id
just a historic group
of soldiers
the chinese had struck the eighth army
like a giant steamroller crushing many
units and
mauling most others eighth army's
commander lieutenant general
walton walker who had said in july of
as the first real southward began
quote there will be no dunk kirk there
will be no baton
a retreat to busan would be the greatest
butcheries
of in history we must fight until the
end
end quote now found himself directing
yet another brave but bloody
withdrawal to the south
only seven years before general
eisenhower's forces
were similarly surprised and smashed
but that time we'd had patent to save
the day
in my heart of hearts i kind of wished
someone would get the idea to use our
recon
company to be the spearhead to bastogne
for the korean conflict
but it was not to be in just as well
unlike the
750 second recon which had 17
m24 light tanks we were a light-skinned
force with only six m24s in the whole
company
divide these up amongst three identical
platoons
and it wasn't exactly the punch
lieutenant colonel creighton abrams had
in 1944. still we had plenty to do to
keep us occupied
exchanging ground for time
the drill went that we would hold the
position until the enemy was breathing
hot and heavy down our necks and we
would break contact and run like hell
leap frogging through another recon
platoon or rifling unit that was set up
behind us in the same way
so they're doing a cover and move as
they're retreating
trading ground for time it was a
dangerous game with no room for error
and we found ourselves
playing it day after day after day
they were strange dudes the chinese
seemingly with no sense of personal
peril
that's a bold statement seemingly with
no
sense of personal peril
that's a human instinct of
self-preservation
and they didn't seem to have it
you know when uh when seth stone went
into sauder city you know
that was in 2008 we had fought in ramadi
in 2006
and he i was talking to him while he was
there you know after the first couple
operations that they ran
and he said something similar i don't
remember the exact quote of what he said
but what he was trying to explain to me
was
the fighters in ramadi were perhaps
better fighters more tactically skilled
he said but
he's like these guys in sadder city they
don't care
they don't care if they die and they are
just coming
and it's a different type of threat but
it's a different scenario that you're
under
it was not unusual to see them jump on a
u.s tank
holding grenades and then scramble
around looking for some opening to toss
them in
of course if the tank was buttoned up it
was impossible and the tank commander
inside would simply call another tank
nearby to quote
scratch my back which at which point the
second tank would spray the first tank
with 30 caliber
coaxial machine gun fire and wash the
hitchhikers off
but there were always other chinamen to
take the dead ones places
it was a grim fact that we were
constantly reminded of as we were moving
south
morale dropped with every rearward step
of the humiliating
retreat that is the just
important to remember that when things
aren't going right when you're in a
leadership position
and things aren't going right and you
have to retreat or you have to take a
tactical withdrawal
or you have to undo some of the progress
that you've made or you have to abandon
some of the work that you've done which
this
is i'm not just talking about war i'm
talking about any scenario business
life you've got when you have to retreat
you have to pay attention to the morale
the troops because it sucks
it sucks and what it sucks is it sucks
the morale right away from the troops
they've put forth this effort they've
fought and bled or they've worked really
hard to get to a certain point and now
you're leaving
we kept falling back away from the yalu
beyond pyongyang
until we'd refocused the 38th parallel
and we were back in south korea the only
thing i think running faster than the
8th armor
were the rumors the marines were cut off
at a place called the chosen reservoir
in the north and were being zeroed out
the u.s army 10 corps had surrendered
boats were waiting at busan harbor to
take us to japan these are all just
crazy rumors that are going around
partially true partially untrue
maybe meanwhile while inner winter had
arrived but winner gear had not
macarthur had said we'd be
home before christmas
i guess his supply people believed him
because the chinese had caught us with
our pants down and they were
summer trousers feet and leather boots
froze
gloves and mittens were scarce as good
looking girls our field jackets were as
thin as
and protective as page one of the
newspaper
we were slowly freezing to death in the
bitter below
zero weather while the chinese like
genghis khan's mighty hordes
marched on seemingly unstoppable
logistics wins wars and here you are
it's crazy to think about this
uh compared to either napoleon's march
into russia which we've covered on this
podcast
with the memories of a napoleonic foot
soldier
and how everyone oh we will be we don't
need winter stuff we should be done by
winter
and then same thing with the nazis going
into russia
and stalingrad freezing how come we
don't learn these lessons how come
that you know this has something to do
with i was talking about the other day
when you come up with a freaking plan
you need to have a negative attitude
your attitude can't be we're gonna be
home by christmas
that's just wrong your attitude has to
be
this could take five years or more
we need to be ready for the worst case
scenario
going in there and thinking we'll be
home by christmas like let's
if that if if if macarthur uttered that
one time which he did
think of the effect and impact that has
on the rest of the chain of command
think of the impact that that has on the
whole supply logistics chain
when they go oh you know it's gonna be
over by christmas i guess it's not
really that important that we get
good boots for the men i guess it's
really not that important that we get
good warm jackets for the men
just a little hint of that
yeah i feel like i kind of fall into
that trap a lot of times you know when
you're going somewhere
and you know what that is that is a an
extreme
form of decentralized command it's an
extreme form
of commander's intent
right so so lately i've been talking
about the fact that culture
is culture
is like the most premier
highest form of decentralized command
and commander's intent
because if our culture is for instance
hey we always take care of the customer
yeah right then you echo charles
as a frontline guy working at a cash
register
you can make a decision on what to do
with a customer because you know that
our customers
most important thing if you know that
listen
we always we always treat civilians
with the utmost respect that's our
culture when you get into a situation
where there's a wounded
you know a wounded mom and a house with
a building
you make that a priority and you take
care of and you get medevac
and and casualty care for that
individual right because that's our
culture
so culture is like the highest form of
decentralized command
well what happens
when you give commanders intent just by
saying something is
innocent as will be home by christmas
think of how that rev
reverberates throughout the the
organization
everybody goes ah we're good because
can you think about the herculean
efforts that it takes to get you know
200 000 warm jackets and pairs of boots
in specific sizes
that's no no joke you can't just snap
your fingers and that happens it's going
to take
ever it's going to take effort at every
level people stepping up to make things
happen
you know like in a communist country
when i remember when the
polish were kind of uh striking
against the against the the
communist regime there they would just
make little small mistakes in factories
right you can prevent things from
happening by just
doing a little bit just by just dragging
your feet just a little bit
because echo if you drag your feet just
a little bit hey maybe it's not that big
of a deal
but if there's a hundred people and
you're all dragging your feet
we're not making progress anymore so you
picture an entire supply chain
that hears eh it'll be over by christmas
how much effort's
being put forth you know sure do you
have some really great people in there
somewhere that are going to get after it
yeah you do
does that overcome the other 94 of the
people that are dragging their feet and
it's not that big of a deal and
hey i'm gonna still head home at four
o'clock today yeah
yeah the jacket thing but
you know how like when you go somewhere
i don't know to the park
carnival whatever and you you kind of
don't account for the weather or
you know like when the sun goes down you
do account for the weather
no but i know where you're going with
this yeah like to me the weather as i
look outside
and boom there's your weather yeah
exactly
but meanwhile my wife is like oh bring
the jacket bring the water just in case
they get thirsty
and you get there you know whatever all
this stuff she's bringing these bags
i was like bro i don't need bags you
know i don't need all this stuff i'm
going to the park all i need is me
really and so does she let you learn
your lesson each and every time
yeah pretty much yeah you go there and
here's the thing that in i mean in my
particular case which you know maybe
this applies to others as well
where i won't learn the lesson every
single time because sometimes i'm like
fine you know sometimes i do make it
home you reinforce
you reinforce the lesson of being a
slacker yes exactly right
so you're right this is not an easy
lesson to learn okay so you
we live collectively you and i at this
time we live in
san diego california and what's
interesting about san diego california
is if you go out to dinner let's say
right now what is it october 2020.
if you go out for dinner at
six o'clock at night the sun is still up
and it's
it's warm outside it's 80 degrees yeah
there's no need for a jacket isn't even
conceivable right
but if you're going to eat outside and
the sun's going to go down it is going
to get
chilly it's going to get chilly it's
going to get
50 degrees that's going to happen in you
know three four hours
so yes when you yeah when you're used to
that scenario being the case it like
gets easier or whatever
but man yeah it does kind of take this
weird mindset i had that exact scenario
happened by the way
like the like a week ago whatever my
wife's birthday we go to
this ra it's called like sea level i
don't know one of these
you know i've been there yeah i know
actually uh
yes some of the guys there said that
you've been there before
at the restaurant so i was like all
right cool um
but one of our people works there yeah
yeah one of our jiu-jitsu people oh yeah
yeah yeah fully
um so yeah so i go there
so we go and you know it's war it's kind
of high it's been hot
so i'm like all right same tactics right
look outside what's the weather like oh
we're sitting outside cool i look
outside weather hot sunny
whatever cool and here's the thing my
wife kind of felt like she didn't fall
for it but she kind of was like
kind of was feeling the same thing so i
was like whatever
no jackets didn't bring jackets for the
kids nothing like that so we go in there
and our seats
are yes outside but covered
it's a little bit of an ocean breeze
going through there and here's the thing
wasn't cold
i wouldn't call it cold but it was
something like you had like chicken skin
every once in a while
you wanted that lightweight light weight
hoodie would have been perfect
it would have been perfect another thing
is it wasn't about me
it was about the kids everybody else you
get a
four-year-old and a seven-year-old
that's just slightly uncomfortable
and chilly they might not throw a
tantrum but you're gonna hear about it
you can learn this lesson it's a good
lesson and you seem to have to learn it
over and over again some of my kids know
it
yeah they think you know they're
bringing i was gonna meet my
meet my family like i i think we were
recording one day and i was gonna meet
my family
somewhere eating outside covered
you gotta eat outside and whatnot right
so
but my son actually just showed up
with a sweatshirt for me
credit right and full credit gets full
credit on that one
yeah because that's like and really the
whole reason is like bro
why do i wanna why am i gonna wear
myself down carrying this
jacket when i probably won't need it why
am i gonna carry this
you know bag of additional clothing
when we're not gonna need all this stuff
or this big
bottle of water you know bro there's
water there
you know like why are you bringing all
this stuff like stop loading like
you know anyway so yeah but
again like you have that mindset you're
gonna get jammed up or potentially
get jammed up in the you know in the
future you gotta plan for that kind of
stuff
which i think my wife is like
that's her whole jam he's like what do
we need she'll overdo it you know
yeah but i'll under do it i think like
the answer the solutions right there in
the middle
hope you guys can find a balance
responsibly
evaluate future scenarios yes
they were not only short on cold weather
gear
continuing on back to the book food was
in short supply
all spare time was spent scrounging one
of the most modern armies in the world
became an
army of days past foraging and living
off the land we kicked in the walls of
houses
searching for rice and kimchi hidden in
false walls and secret caches
we cooked what we found in our steel
pots
when nothing else was available we'd
take the sea ration packets of sugar
powdered coffee
powdered milk and chocolate we'd stored
for days like squirrels and the pockets
of our fatigues mash it all together
with snow on our helmets and trick
or trick ourselves into believing it was
ice cream
trying to beat the elements became a war
in itself it was so
bitterly cold you couldn't sleep you had
to keep moving stomping feet and flexing
fingers 24 hours a day
those who didn't were saying goodbye to
their hands and feet and in some cases
their lives
for a while every day a couple men were
evacuated because of frostbite
black toes and fingers to be cut off at
the hospital grenades knives and ammo
would freeze fast to the foxhole brim
weapons froze too you'd have to kick the
bolts of the m1 and browning automatic
rifles to get them back
we seldom had rifle patches to clean our
weapons most of us cut little squares
out of our shirts or trousers
to do the best we could gun oil was a
luxury usually beyond our
reach we lubricated our weapons with
motor oil
or the frozen lard of sea rations and
took to keeping them with us in our fart
sacks at night
staying alive became our only concern
and we did
man is most adaptable when we passed
through villages if a house had a lot of
wood
doors window frame even the most
beautiful hand carved furniture
we'd burn it one piece at a time
finishing off the job by throwing a
thermite grenade on the thatched roof
and standing by until the whole
structure was burned to the ground
our orders were to destroy anything the
enemy could use
gladly we thought to ourselves and we
could stay warm while we did it
at night we would carefully obsessively
bundle stack and restack kindling wood
while waiting for daybreak when we could
light our fires the thought of those
friendly flames allowed us to make it
through the night
instantaneously at first light thousands
of tiny fires would spring up across the
front and around each
huddled a cluster of shivering men it
was probably as bad in the chinese camp
except that
at least the chinks were prepared with
winter gear
down trousers and jackets long overcoats
that blended in with the snow
and down mittens that we liberated and
wore until our own supply people
came through it was a frigid brutal
soul-destroying time i knew
then how the their mark i knew then how
the vermark
must have felt during world war ii or
how napoleon's army must have suffered
years and years before that
when each made their horrible winter
retreat from russia
like i said this just savage
frigid brutal soul destroying time
and this is coming from the perspective
of a guy that you know
served multiple combat tours in vietnam
as well
by the time we reached seoul the north
korean capital once a bustling city of
millions was virtually deserted an empty
gray tomb
most of its inhabitants and those in the
of the northern villages on its
outskirts
had left and headed south with the few
possessions they could carry
clogging the roads with wall-to-wall
human misery
on one occasion american fighter planes
must have concluded that the hordes
of desperate civilians were chinese
columns moving south
p-51s had strafed the refugees
and for at least a mile they were dead
littered across the road
retreating vehicles had to push the
bodies out of the way
it was here that i realized it was only
the guys on the ground
who saw and understood the real horrors
of war to air force pilots
war is a remote thing they make their
kills from hundreds or thousands of feet
in the air
even the guys who fly on the deck do so
in a flash dropping their loads and
flying away without seeing the results
the way homes and people are blown to
smithereens or the effects of napalm
at night they don't didn't have to
listen as we did in the winter of 1950
to the whale of the gooks cries of
civilian refugees begging to be let
through american lines
or see in the morning when they were
allowed to pass through
the dead they'd left behind those who'd
frozen to death
in open rice paddies overnight
the pilot when he finishes his day's
work
flies back to his base lands goes to the
club
has a big stake and if he wants to
forget the day's
combat he can drink himself into a
stupor
the frontline fighter can't do that he
lives with death
and the horror of the battlefield every
day and every night
it is his cross to bear
we continued retreating gray
rotting bodies the unforgettable smell
of death
rats feasting on the dead and growing
boulder by the day
this the flotsam jetsam of war
led us through soul our unit's mission
was to fight a rear guard
action in the center of the city the
scout section rifle squad set up at a
downtown intersection
we took over a bank a drug store and two
other corner buildings
for my command post i'd use the bank's
managers plush office which was a
welcome diversion from the cold and snow
the bank vault was locked tight as the
self-appointed new bank manager
i authorized the guys to open it with
their 3.5
anti-tank bazooka two rounds later the
door swung open as easy as a sea ration
can
in the hands of a hungry trooper the
vault contained thousands of dollars in
small korean notes
all the big stuff was gone i told
everyone to cash in
no no withdrawal forms needed i said
and they did we had to laugh at the
propaganda leaflets at the chinese
mortar down
upon us from the hills they occupied on
the high ground around seoul
quote american capitalists running dogs
of wall street they accused
how right they are i thought as we
stuffed our pockets and packs
and even made hobo sacks to carry our
spoils of war
it was strange watching the chinese
brazenly looking down from those hills
about six or eight hundred yards away
our infantry weapons were out of range
preventing a little selective sniping
but we were able to put some effective
fire on them with the m24s main gun
and had the great fun of taking pot
shots with the turret's 50 cal
the chinese went to ground and shy of a
cheerless christmas
we slipped out of the sad near deserted
soul
my section's new found wealth was the
first thing to be tossed on the side of
the road
bulky dollars meant nothing meant little
to warn out troopers
and it had been just a game anyway
south of seoul we found ourselves caught
in a friendly battle zone
a railway yard being blasted to kingdom
come by demolition toting engineers and
air force bombers
railroad flat cars complete with brand
new vehicles and tanks
which would have been distributed to the
front lines had it not collapsed
were being blown sky-high to keep them
out of enemy lines
to us in the middle the challenge of
this army obstacle
course was not only to avoid our own
flying debris
but also the enemy incoming which was
pouring in throughout the operation
yeah that's that's a scary sight so
you've got
and it shows you that i guess it shows
not scary it's the desperation of the
situation that you're in
that you've got however many numbers of
vehicles that were going to be shipped
up to the front time and now we're just
blowing them in place so that the enemy
doesn't capture them
you want to talk about a merol a morale
crusher
we came upon the number of freight cars
with sealed doors
one of the guys pried one open to reveal
an entire car load of px supplies
soap cigarette aftershave lotion
obviously goodies needed by our rear
echelon comrades
and we decided to help ourselves someone
drove a brand new
three-quarter ton truck off a nearby
flat car
so we had a way to get away with had a
way to get to carry out our loot
it fell about four feet and crashed to
the ground springs breaking fenders
collapsing
but it still ran that's a comic scene
right you got this vehicle on a flat pit
on a flat uh freight train and just
drive it off
duke's a hazard style
we loaded our spoils onto the truck even
as telephone poles
and large chunks of steel rained down
around us then we jumped aboard
ourselves
and unasked the place eight recon men
bouncing along in a light
in a in a truck right out of the grapes
of wrath we motored by a battalion
infantry hiking south down the road
hey how you fixed for cigarettes we
called an aqua velva anyone as we threw
all the troopers a little something we
ran out of goodies about the same time
our mobile pack px
ran out of gas and we reluctantly turned
to the return to the backs of our tanks
with the rest of our platoon we were
young
sometimes the war was great fun like a
game of cops and robbers or cowboy and
indians
that you played as kids
you know it's from a maturity level
right
that's something that's just so
it's important to remember man that
you're dealing with people that are 19
20 years old 21 years old i mean hack
was one of the older guys
but most of these guys a lot of these
guys when you go into the military
it's young kids
when i went in i was 18 years old
like i'm a you know my judgment uh
you know when you talk about the what is
it the development of the prefrontal
cortex right
which as a man doesn't develop until
you're something like 25.
yes sir so you gotta you gotta find your
way through seven years of military
service
where your freaking decision-making
process is not fully developed yet
that's how dumb [ __ ] happens yeah makes
sense
you do dumb [ __ ] that's why leadership
is so important in the military
but the thing is sometimes the military
leaders are only 23.
they're still not even there yet
continuing on the politics or purpose of
the war was not our concern
we didn't understand or care about the
big picture any more than we really
understood the risks of combat
of being killed or going home without a
leg after a while you stopped worrying
if the next minute you were going to get
it
instead you just prayed for a clean
wound so you could get out of there
a million dollar wound to get you home
you know what was crazy when we had dean
lad on and he was going into tarawa
where the japanese had a freaking island
fortress and i asked him i was like will
you worry about getting warned
wounded or anything and he's like no
that would be someone else
that's the deal man it's not going to
happen to me
after we retreated across the han river
my platoon was given the mission to
outpost a long
lonely stretch of the south bank it was
christmas day
and although there were no chinese in
sight it wasn't a particularly jolly
time
general walker had been killed two days
before in a freak
jeep truck accident very similar to the
one that had killed
his former world war ii boss general
patton
still paratroop general matt ridgeway
had taken over as the new commander of
the 8th army and word was we would
retreat no further
it was a good word but my platoon had a
more immediate concern
we were starving a personal recon of the
area revealed a village nearby
whose only occupants were a half a dozen
scroungy looking chickens
one long burst from my borrowed m2
carbine gave us christmas dinner
in the form of three decisively dead
birds that we plucked
and threw on an open fire we ate them
unseasoned and undercooked
they were very very raw in fact but
wonderful to us
and we gobbled them down and huddled
closer to the fire
thinking how lucky we were
no sooner had we finished then a recon
company jeep and trailer bounced across
the field to
our positions christmas dinner turkey
cranberry sauce and all the trimmings
had arrived
only the american army could do that
unfortunately our chicken appetizer had
left
all of us with roaring gut aches
but we wolfed it down anyways because it
was good because it was there and
because none of us knew
if this meal would be the last the enemy
took seoul
just after the new year the bridge
across the han had been
blown but a few days later the chinks
got a bridge head across
and we once again headed south in zero
degree weather
with our tails between our legs so much
for no more retreats
began to think about all the generals
proclamations
concerning this war that we'd be home
before christmas
that the chinese would not intervene
that we'd hold here
we'd hold there all of it was [ __ ]
and i started to wonder how they could
possibly make so many dumb statements
when each in invariably fell apart when
put to the test
then i thought well maybe they just
don't
know we never saw a general
on the front we seldom saw a colonel a
lieutenant colonel
or a major either and at the squad level
we only on the rarest occasion saw a
captain
so how could the brass know how defeated
its army was
if it wasn't there to see or if they
weren't there to see an exhausted guy
lie down on a road and just give up
[Music]
how could they know how cold and
ill-equipped we were
if they weren't there to see blue
gloveless hands
stick to the frozen metal of weapons
how could they know how steep and rugged
the terrain was
if they never climbed a hill
a little leadership lesson there massive
leadership lesson there
you have to find out what's going on
with the front line troops
and you can't rely on reports and you
know i was reading
some other sections of this book
and and the temptation to just listen to
the reports of frontline troops in any
organization
is a it's a massive temptation and it's
the wrong thing to do
because of course when you're in charge
of course your subordinates are going to
polish that thing
up for you make it look all good
make it look all good that's what
they're going to do
you can't rely on that you have to go
down there
and the other thing you have to do is
you have to be able to admit when you
don't know something
so the front when you say the frontline
troops like they'll polish like
their report yeah that's like why do
they do
it just to to show like hey we're doing
a good job down here kind of thing
or or they don't want to get anyone in
trouble or like
to not to go super philosophically deep
on you right now
but a lack of moral courage good job a
lack of
moral courage to report to your boss my
men are frozen starving and they're
ready to give up
because what you're doing is you look
you're the leader and so you're putting
yourself on rapport for not being a good
leader
right because you know there's no bad
teams only bad leaders
all right oh like the leader of the
front line so yeah so if i'm a leader in
the front if you're general echo
and and my guys haven't eaten and their
their
their morale is breaking i don't want to
tell you that because then you'll be
like well what's wrong with you
how come because guess what fred over
there he's like my men are doing great
right because he has no moral courage to
actually tell the truth about what's
happening
yeah yeah and and and then that puts
pressure on me where now i'm thinking
uh oh i mean fred's doing well maybe my
guys
maybe my guys can do better and okay you
know what general echo
uh we're fine yeah
yeah that's true so it's a lack of moral
courage
yeah it seems natural too now now that
i'm kind of thinking of it like that
especially yeah if you're in charge of
the guys over there
you don't want to you want to be like
yeah we're uh
we're not doing good yeah even like it's
kind of seems like even in like social
scenarios you know
for sure do that like we're like hey so
how's uh
how's married life or so i don't know
whatever whatever the situation is
and you want to be like i'm struggling
through this married life kind of thing
like it's like you don't want to say
that
if in fact you're struggling through
marriage tonight i'm just saying yeah it
seems like
yeah that seems a lot more natural yeah
obviously it happens in the business
world too because
you know the oh how echo how's your
sales going with your sales team down
there yeah
you know you don't want to say well it's
not going very well because you're
putting yourself on report from
for for failing yeah because you are the
leader
but if there's stuff what you should say
what you should say is hey boss here's
what's going on
my troops they're over fatigued right
now we need food
and we need some warm weather gear
because look there's some there's some
motorbike there's some motivated guys
that want to make it happen
but when they can't even load their
weapon because their skin
is freezing to the bullets
that is a problem a problem that no
amount of motivation can cure
we need gloves like that kind of thing
yeah yeah you have to be able to frame
it correctly
back to the book still we kept
retreating exchanging ground for time
we were always cold always hungry always
tired we were all so
filthy it was too cold to even consider
washing so we got to
sue juan and found ourselves with a few
days to rest we decided to take that
abandoned city by storm
as in seoul everyone had left sue won in
a great hurry
so we could pretty well help us help
ourselves to whatever we needed
my section took over a house we
scrounged around and found an
old-fashioned korean bath one of those
stand-up jobs about chest high with a
wood furnace beneath it
we filled the tub built a roaring fire
and one by one
jumped in each of us skimming the other
guy's dirt off the top of the water i
was last
the water was almost black by then with
all kinds of crud floating around but i
didn't care
i might not have gotten clean but for
the first time in weeks i was warm
just after we left suwon my platoon was
ordered to establish a night blocking
position a stride
a north-south road that paralleled a
railroad track
the scout section and rifle squad were
set up on in a defensive line that ran
from the road through a rice paddy and
onto a railroad trestle
our machine gun was set up on the
trestle pointing straight down the
tracks
a little high ground where it could put
plunging fire directly in front of
deployed troops and flanking fire on the
road 50 yards away
our platoon leaders stayed with the two
m24 tanks on the road behind him
was the 81 millimeter mortar squad it
was late at night all was quiet
we were locked and cocked and pros at
this deadly delaying game now
i moved between positions having
whispered conversations with the guys
it was a habit i had to keep myself
awake and make sure the men stayed awake
too
i was the i was at the machine gun which
was manned by a stud of a hawaiian
trooper named sheldon when we saw the
enemy coming
there was at least a company and maybe
more behind four abreast double timing
quietly down the railroad track
when they were no more than fifth thirty
yards from the machine gun
sheldon let loose a long burst that cut
a wide swath into their unsuspecting
ranks
a burst of machine gun fire was the
signal for the infantry tanks and
mortars to join the fray
the scout section and rifle squad
immediately poured fire into the enemy
formation
the enemy panicked they did not fire one
round in return
instead they broke ranks and hightailed
it to the rice paddy
running right into the rifle squads
grazing fire it was great to see
we were cleaning the clock of an enemy
force at least 10 times our size
like young rommel did i thought in 1914
when he ambushed and destroyed almost a
complete british rifle company
with a handful of soldiers simply by
using initiative
and surprise two of the key elements in
battle
the mortar was plopping rounds of high
explosives right on top of the confused
reds meanwhile
our tank's main guns which were loaded
with anti-personnel grape shot
hadn't fired anything at all
a white star cluster flare popped and
hovered over our positions
this was our signal to beat feet in
retreat
and we didn't need a second invitation
we scrambled
to waiting vehicles and quickly moved
to and through u.s lines we'd taken no
casualties
but i still couldn't understand why the
tanks guns
hadn't fired the enemy had been hurt
badly but not destroyed
if those tank guns had been employed
we'd have completely wiped them out
the sun was coming up as the platoon
pulled into the abandoned chonan
school yard that served as the base for
recon company
i went over to our platoon sergeant and
asked him why the tanks hadn't been used
he looked away and sort of bowed his
head as if he was embarrassed
which was very strange behavior for this
rugged highly decorated warrior
better see the lieutenant young sergeant
why didn't the tanks fire i asked my
regular army platoon leader moments
later
i didn't want to give our positions away
he replied
i couldn't believe it give your
positions away
[ __ ] i cried sergeants didn't talk
to officers like that but i didn't care
we had the closest thing to a glorious
victory that i'd seen the chinks stuck
their noses into this goddamn war
that i've seen since the chinks stuck
and now this piss ant weak lieutenant
you were just too yellow to do your job
i shouted and stormed back into my scout
section
in a rage i grabbed my pack and rifle
i'm leaving this outfit right now i told
my platoon sergeant
i'm not waiting for orders i'm going
awol
i came here to fight not play hide and
seek and where i come from
officers like you've got here would have
been drummed right out of the officer's
core
and with that i headed for the road
so that's just mayhem right they they
don't
actively assault the enemy with all the
firepower that they had
hackworth gets pissed off so he goes
awol
now normally absent without leave what
someone's trying to do is they're trying
to shirk responsibility you know they're
a hippie or they're a bum and they're
trying to get out of there
they're they're what for whatever reason
they're trying to leave they're trying
to get away from the army
he's going awol because he wants to
fight more
there was a uh expression in there
and i've heard it before uh their ranks
like he referred to
like we shot bullets into their ranks
and then they broke rank
right like what assembled in a formation
type thing
like lined up yeah which is crazy to
think about
it's crazy to think about in modern war
a group of individuals being in ranks
so in ranks is like you know four across
and whatever 30 deep
that's a specific formation assemblance
or is it just sort of
just them over there in that whatever i
mean the fact that he's saying
in ranks means that they're in a
legitimate
formation yeah you know they're probably
moving
down this road they don't think there's
any americans there to interfere with
them so they're just
in ranks walking because it's an
efficient way to walk yeah but it's not
an efficient way to fight
yeah it doesn't seem like it's an
efficient way to get mowed down by
machine gun which is exactly what
happened
yes yeah i could see that well yeah and
so when they broke ranks they all ran
in different directions yeah you know so
well let me ask you this as far as just
in the spirit of understanding what that
means because it sounds real cool
in my opinion like i could just be
throwing out that expression from time
to time
not in a military sense but you know i
don't know i don't know
well they do use it in a non-military
sense let's say
there's 20 people and where we come up
with a plan
and we're going to go forward with this
new plan and then echo decides he's
going to do something different
there's an expression oh echo just broke
ranks okay yes
exactly right and that's kind of what i
was sort of trying to figure out
like could i use it in that way yes you
can because it sounds really cool
when instead of like oh yeah i just
started shooting at all of them you know
i shot into their ranks you know like
that sounds way cooler
but so could it be even loosely used
in in an official on an official
situation
um of just a group of people there you
know yeah
right like they weren't a little bit
necessarily in a specific formation but
they were over there
delivered i would say that was a bunch
of people yeah
i would say that was a crowd of people
right right you say there's a
a bunch of people in ranks yeah they're
organized
yeah well could they be interpreted as
organized you know like
you know the kind where those two guys
let's say not military maybe like i
don't know your friends in the
neighborhood
and you don't like them you know a bunch
of cousins or whatever you don't like
them
and they're over there on the corner
right and you have maybe you and your
brother whatever
right you guys don't like them they
don't like you whatever and then
you see them over there on the corner
assembled not for any specific reason
but they're together you know
could you could you in theory refer to
them as the
on the corner in ranks in theory yes you
could but it wouldn't be accurate two
people is not going to equivalent
no the cousins let's say there's five
five cousins even five
you're going to have a hard time getting
you know being in ranked
people no to me they're in ranks so
you're asking me for permission to use
this word and then you're just
when i tell you no you're just doing it
anyways yes sir cool say whatever you
want to say
it's your you're the one that's going to
look
you're the one that's going to look dumb
and i didn't want to say it but like
this is where we're at and you sounded
like you really did want to say it but
if i hesitate if if i pause if this is
the right thing to do call my friend
dumb well i guess it is
my friend wants to act dumb he's going
to get called though he can't just
decide what you're going to call
something
look if there's five there's definitions
on the corner all together cruising
and me and my brother start running at
them aggressively and they scatter
they broke ranks okay there you go
so then now i guess i'm dumb because
they you know would have been in some
form of ranks
yeah so i i just i i look at this as
like an understanding process
do you understand yes sir i do thank you
i'm not even sure i understand everybody
[Music]
so hackworth goes awol because he wants
to fight more
back to the book any man who's wild
enough to go awol to fight is just the
kind of man we want in our outfit
said captain john paul van when i
stopped
at his eighth ranger camp fresh from my
breakfast out of the 25th recon company
the eighth rangers was a great spirited
outfit recently rebuilt after being
decimated the night the chinese entered
the war
after i'd explained my situation the
whole outfit accepted me with open arms
the rangers were elite troops
forerunners of the special forces
their mission was raids long
reconnaissance patrols ambushes and
other special jobs
that conventional troops were not
trained to handle their history went
back to rogers rangers
before the revolutionary war during
world war
ii there had been six ranger battalions
whose brave and daring feats are
unmatched to this day historically such
all volunteers specif
specially trained units had been misused
tasked either with impossible missions
for organizations their size
or placed with palace guard combat
duties well beneath their skill and
ability
when i arrived at the eighth ranger camp
the unit was chasing gorillas behind the
main lines
morale was high and the guys were
spoiling for a good fight
but during the time i was there
there was nothing much to my way of
thinking anyway
that seemed to be happening i was
impatient to get in the thick of it
and as proud as i was to be a ranger
guerrilla hunting was not my idea of
infantry combat little did i know
then the starring roles that gorilla
hunting and ranger ceo
john paul van would have later in my
life besides
the word was that the eighth rangers was
going to be broken up soon
and something in me said to move on so i
did until i saw
a sign by a road that proclaimed
wolfhound
right white rear well if that's not a
guarantee for a good fight i don't know
what is i thought
and hightailed it to the battalion cp
the 27th infantry wolfhound regiment
was a colorful unit itself the outfit
had gotten its name during a stint in
fighting the communists in siberia
during the russian revolution in korea
the wolf hounds were known as the fire
brigade
because whenever there was trouble they
were sent in to
save the day they weren't a special unit
just a group of guys who thought they
were good
so they were good i had to highlight
that because that just
teaches you something about leadership
and about morale
and about attitude and about esprit de
corps
you get guys and you convince them that
they're good and they think they're good
they get good they become good i'd seen
members of the outfit regularly
over the last months whenever the 25th
recon had sent their portions
of the division was sent had been sent
their portion of the divisional front
and i'd always been
knocked out by the because these guys
acted more like pirates
on the high seas than as a regular army
regiment to begin with
the wolf hounds wore their regimental
crust crest on their fatigues like their
medal of honor
their spirit was just incredible they
were so totally non-military in terms of
what i was accustomed to
they seldom wore steel pots they
modified their gear to make it more
functional and simply got rid of things
that weighed them down
unnecessarily the long wooden handle of
the entrenching tool for example was cut
off so it wouldn't rub against your leg
the packs were thrown away and you
carried a tramps roll
which was quickly grounded when you got
into a fight
bars were stripped of bipods and
carrying handles
and scabbards were tossed with the
bayonet living permanently at the end of
the rifle
grenades were carried in canteen covers
you could fit
five and if you wanted to carry a
captured weapon
go for it so these guys are got a little
a little bit of rebellion in them got a
little rebellious attitude which is a
good thing
got to be balanced but it's a good thing
this renegade kind of soldiering was not
only sanctioned but encouraged
by the 27th regimental commander and
fire chief world war ii paratrooper
colonel john iron mike
michaelis michaelis who would go on to
four stars
understood what made men fight
he was known for morale boosting slogans
like you're lean you're mean you're
rough you're tough
you're professional killers and
pre-battle pep talks like
you're not here to die for your country
you're here to make those other
so-and-so's die for theirs
the wolf hounds proud proud combat
record showed that they believed him
and they had eagerly adopted their
commander's no-nonsense brand of
soldiering
i was more than ready to do the same
the second battalion's exo pointed the
way up the road to where the rifle
companies were deployed
the first unit i came to was company g
where i reported to first sergeant
edwin rager
i can always use another sergeant this
giant of a top kick roared
then and there he assigned me the third
platoon finally with the assurance
that i'd be picked up on the morning
report so i wouldn't be considered a
waller
or mia i joined my new family
at first it was not the happiest of
unions
i should have realized it wouldn't be
easy it's always a [ __ ] to join a unit
particularly one as tight as the wolf
hounds as an
individual replacement and for some
reason it's even worse
when you're an nco or an officer you
don't know anyone
and no one trusts you until you've
proved yourself in battle
you get all the lousy details and only
the worst battlefield horror stories
you're just the new guy you're just
fresh meat
and add insult to injury though i'd been
a squad leader and
acting platoon sergeant in italy and a
section leader in the 25th recon
now in the in the third of the g i found
myself
an assistant squad leader i was damned
unhappy with the demotion i probably had
more non-calm experience than
any of the squad leaders in the platoon
but the fact was that in their eyes i
was untried
and all protest to the contrary fell on
deaf ears
doesn't matter who you are hackworth
checking into a new unit
got to prove yourself it didn't help
i didn't help my cause that any that
evening soon after my arrival
when just at dusk i got caught in a
right in a rice paddy right smack dab
in the middle of a blistering [ __ ]
mortar attack
i started to run but slipped and fell in
the patty when i finally got back to my
foxhole i discovered that my water
repellent
outer trousers were covered with human
[ __ ]
which the koreans used for fertilizer
unsurprisingly the guy sharing my hole
was unhappy about this
as i was i took off the trousers and
made do for the night with two pairs of
long johns
and two pairs of od trousers i had on
underneath
then i sacked out until it was my turn
to go on guard leaving my foxhole
partner
to contend with the lingering aroma of
my accident
guard was grew a grueling ritual mainly
because
everyone was so tired each squad had its
own sector
normally four foxholes each about four
yards apart
the two guys shared a hole and took
turns throughout the night searching
into the darkness
you'd look until you got tired then
glance at your buddy sacked out
at the bottom of the hole then you'd
look a little longer until
while you thought should i wake him now
has he had enough sleep
few guys had watches to own a watch in
an infantry squad
during the first korean winter was a
luxury beyond imagination
so you spelled each other based on the
honor system and you only asked for
relief when it was impossible to keep
your eyes open any longer
then your buddy would ask for a sit rep
and that was it
you'd be asleep almost before you'd
zipped up your feather down
fart sack that's what they call those
sleeping bags if you didn't pick that up
the last time i used it
guys didn't even have watches
what's happening i asked when my foxhole
partner
woke me for my turn not a thing he
replied and he was out like a light
still inside my sack i sat in the
darkness in the edge of the hole
got my eyeballs unglued and tried to
remember where i was i was fantasizing
about smoking a cigarette drinking a hot
cup of coffee
eating a charcoal black rare steak and
getting
a squad of my own when to my amazement
i saw a man lying prone immediately
to my immediate left rear i woke up my
buddy there's a goddamn chick almost on
top of us
we whispered through our options we
could toss a grenade
blast him with a rifle or crawl out and
get him with a knife we decided on the
third alternative
because the guy was right in the middle
of our squad position and rifle fire or
a grenade
could easily start a firefight among our
own guys
the [ __ ] wasn't moving and his back was
to us my buddy covered me
while i crawled out of the foxhole with
my trusty m1 and 10 inch razor sharp
bayonet attached i crouched in a crouch
position
i silently slipped up behind the enemy
soldier when i got within sticking
distance i drew my rifle
and thrust it with full force
branches crackled and it was over
i'd bayoneted my own frozen stiff
trousers which i had earlier hung over a
bush behind our foxhole to dry
the next morning i had to put the shitty
things back on again
now with a hole in the ass as well and
for some reason the fresh meat
was the only one in the squad who didn't
think this was very
funny so that's how he that's that's the
impression he makes
his freaking stabbing his own pants and
his own [ __ ] covered pants in the middle
of the night
being a new guy is hard yeah it seems
like it
being a new guy is hard being a new
guide is very hard
you cannot you cannot do these kind of
things it sucks when you do
everyone's watching you yeah
uh you know kind of when you're a new
guy
kind of kind of back off a little bit
you know what i'm saying
yeah like just take take a wrap off yeah
that whole first impression thing just
in general
yeah because like the new guy you don't
have any uh evaluation criteria like
there's no
like you didn't you're not judged on
anything because you don't have anything
you know and then you start doing
these weirdo things stabbing your
expanse you're like okay well that's
how this guy is he stabs his own pants
in the dark sometimes i guess so yeah
you're weird you're weird
and then so now you got to kind of make
up for all that stuff
by doing a bunch of awesome stuff you
know but i i guess even beyond that look
okay so let's admit that it's hard
but i guess what i'm saying is air on
the side
of not doing dumb [ __ ] yeah you know
what i'm saying
like if there's something i could maybe
do this and it might make me look good
but just think about you know once again
be negative when you plan
yeah be negative think to yourself you
know that by me look
might make me look cool but
also if this goes sideways it's going to
look real dumb yeah
uh have you ever seen like fail videos
yes sir it's uh yes sir right yes very
often
i mean those are a legitimate thing
right oh yeah that's an
addiction by the way so how many of
those people
in the five seconds before they attempt
their
whatever they're attempting yeah how
many of those people are actually
thinking this is gonna look
really gonna be awesome yeah yeah so
there's there's two of them there's one
girl one guy and they're the same thing
so it's like oh yeah i'm going to jump
in this icy
pond you know with my the guy obviously
has his swimsuit on the girl that's her
swimsuit or whatever
they're two separate videos that's what
i'm saying but the same thing so they go
you know the girls like this is why i
come to you for this type of expertise
this is where we this is where
the whole world wins right now
this is the ultimate fail video yeah so
one of them
for sure they they're endless and i love
them but you know
great lessons in these videos you know
so yeah
now we're talking about freaking
philosophical lessons we get from fail
videos
yes yes i brought it up they go deep i
brought it up yes
yeah i'm guilty yeah so
you know the girl's like hey okay ready
the guy in the camera may or may not be
in on it whatever
says okay one two three go the girl
jumps off this little pier which is you
know maybe two three
three feet down into the water the icy
water right and the ice is just so thick
that it doesn't even break so she's just
like god
slams onto the ice you could get really
badly hurt oh yeah that's the thing it's
like that's
the gene you can break your neck yeah or
your back or your tailbone and all that
oh yeah oh yeah people break their neck
a lot diving into
shallow pools or shallow you know water
pond water or whatever oh yeah
yeah luckily they they weren't trying to
dive in they were just you know
regular jump oh okay yeah i feel a
little better about it now yeah i don't
think
that wouldn't be a good idea even if it
was thin ice to like dive
that's like some next level like not
smart
that's the next level fail yes sir um
but no
you can still get hurt imagine jumping
off this table onto concrete
slippery conga that's essentially what
it is you know yeah so
you mean ice yeah it's straight
slippery doesn't break doesn't crack and
here's the thing
i'm assuming they didn't get injured i'm
sure it hurt for sure
on a couple levels but when you watch it
it's real funny
because you think they're gonna like do
like a cannonball or whatever and it's
like
it's real funny but yeah man it's that
thing if you're the new guy
and that's what you do it's like man
yeah you're the guy who jumped on that
ice and like jammed yourself
up you know yeah just kind of reassess
in those five seconds
before you're about to do something just
think and look i'm not saying you don't
have to have courage
you got to try things you know but just
think maybe
this isn't gonna quite turn out the way
i wanted it to yeah
is there a chance that this goes a
little bit wrong
it's possible yeah and if you're a new
guy you don't have that much
leadership capital to spend on
recovering from this
yeah so just you got to take risks and
stuff
makes sense back to the book
the war seemed lost at best
it was hopelessly confused i'd thought
wars at least american wars had happy
endings like capturing berlin and tokyo
all we were doing was yo-yoing back and
forth across the korean peninsula
defeat then victory then defeat and
defeat with g
company 2 we were retreating shuffling
along heading south colder sometimes the
temperatures were 20 degrees below
zero and more tired than we'd ever been
in our lives
one day a snap thaw had us wading
through mud on both sides of a mire that
had
once been a road jeeps and trucks
sloshed through it too each vehicle
trying in vain to miss the rut of the
vehicle in front so it's to not become
bogged down
one jeep stalled and would not restart
just as our column was passing by
the driver and lieutenant passenger
unasked the thing the lieutenant called
for help to push it over to the side but
before we could slosh through the
quagmire
and give him a hand he whipped out his
pistol and
aimed at one of the tires i figured his
daddy must have been an old horse
soldier and this guy was going to follow
through with the cav tradition of
shooting his disabled mount
and for sure pow pow pow
but the last shot missed the tire it
glanced off the rim and boomerang back
to strike the lieutenant
right between the eyes we pushed the
jeep and the warm still body off the
road
and then returned to our column soon the
temperature dropped the road turned to
ice and we just kept heading south
it hadn't meant anything the
lieutenant's death for openers
what he'd done was dumb but more than
that
we'd become immune fighting a war on the
ground is like a working in a
slaughterhouse
at first the blood the gore gets to you
but after a while you don't see it
you don't smell it you don't feel it so
what's another dead body
it's almost as if you don't care in this
case
we just leaned forward kept walking and
tried to ignore the song in our heads
the ones the troops called
the bug out blues
so this is the life of a ground pounder
i'd often think
the risks were higher in the recon
company but life in george
was far more harsh at least in recon we
frequently rode on the backs of our
tanks and thus kept warm in the infantry
it was just a plotting grind one foot
after the other until the column stopped
and we'd flop
down the sound sound asleep before our
heads touched the ground
in recon we were seldom hungry because
we stashed rations on the tanks in the
infantry
growling bellies were our constant
companions
in the infantry many men lost their will
to live frequently guys would just quit
drop
out of the moving column and plunk down
on the side of the road sometimes with
the chinese within sight
you'd say come on buddy get up let's go
you're going to be captured
and he'd say i don't care i can't go
another step
a day felt like a week and the more
tired an infantry became
the more tired an infantry man became
the more he wanted to lighten his load
first would go the souvenirs
then his extra ammo next would be the
bulky gear the field coat the pile
jackets and the down sleeping bags
even though he knew he'd freeze that
night
in the infantry i found you live for
right now
you don't give a damn about tomorrow
because you don't even know if there'll
be one
get getting it's weird i know you like
to talk about the
the long game versus the short game
versus the the strategic moves versus
the tactical moves
but it's interesting when you think
about what's happening right now with a
human being and with human beings in
general
as we encounter stress as we encounter
pain and suffering
we start to focus on just a short term
just a short-term win and think about
that you know from a life perspective i
mean here you are you know it's going to
be freezing tonight
you know it's going to be freezing but
you don't want to carry this down
sleeping bag
anymore so you just leave it yeah think
about how crazy that is
but we make decisions all the time that
are that
stupid but we want that short-term
gratification
well in a lot of cases relief
like short-term short-term relief i
guess
as far as the game goes same thing so
it's like
relief gratification you know whatever
yeah like there's a difference but
in the game as far as the game's
concerned that's what you're going for
you know
in like it's like a craving right yeah
craving
like that's a relief from that's crazy
that's throwing away your
your down sleeping bag sleeping bag
that's what it is
it's gonna feel good right now like you
just got rid of three pounds yeah
and by the way back in the day like
these down sleeping bags you know like
nowadays things are
feather like a little bit different you
know this is probably four or five
pounds
which is a big difference when you're
hauling that thing but think about what
that does
think about you're right man it's a
craving right it's when you say oh i
really want to eat those cheetos
you just knock oh i just i just want to
oh i just
those cheetos are going to be good yep
and then
even when after you eat your i don't
know chicken salad or whatever
cheetos still sound kind of good you
know there's still like a little
little thing that needs really just like
you know dumping this
my down parka yeah that could keep me
warm
yeah but i think what it has to do with
see there's a there's this difference
what it has to do with this like one is
caused by suffering
and you just get into this mode of just
basically surrender
maybe that is what happens in life maybe
you get to a point where you just kind
of surrender to where you're at
you just kind of accept like hey this is
just me yeah and now you know
cheetos no cheetos whatever donut no
doughnut oh the doughnut
yeah that's a good way of putting it
accepting where you're at yeah
and it's like because where you're at
can is it's a place in your mind too
you know how like even if you're you're
making progress but you're used to not
making progress you know
when you're really used to it yeah it
can happen like with my like
if you have like a certain amount of
money in your bank account when you're a
kid or
a young man whatever if you're used to
having like
you know 20 in there yeah like just
constantly that's
sort of the baseline or whatever and
then you're like
then you get 100 100 or 500 900.
oh but you're used to having 20 it's
like yeah like i'm making progress i'm
saving money i'm saying
but you're used to having 20. so then
you go out by that big screen tv
there's a chance that that
yeah like you have to like actively
maybe like raise your
for real raise your standard now when
you get the 900 in there now the new
standard is i don't know make it
realistic i guess but
800 should be the standard like the
baseline now you know
so sure you got some wiggle room maybe
you're not perfect maybe it's new to you
okay but the standard is eight like you
start going below eight that's the same
thing as having negative
kind of attitude but you gotta really
establish it in your head you know
it's hard though very very because
people are where they are and they kind
of get used to it
that's why that's why they are where
they are because they're literally used
to it you know
not like like pretend used to it
is it good to get well never mind is it
it's good to get that
new standard and actually stay there
long enough that you
feel it yeah that you get used to the
new standard that's the tricky part yeah
you feel good but then you're like oh
and then you go back to your normal ways
yep first craving that comes about
satisfying the craving
relief from the crate however you want
to put it like even like when you say
suffering it's kind of like
what does that really mean you know i
mean there's certain levels of suffering
for sure
like you can go deep into human
suffering for sure but
really to some people like not having a
drink
suffering you know when they're like or
have a craving for ice cream or
something like this it's like
it's kind of like so it's suffering you
know that's really a
horrible stretch isn't it i mean really
to think like i can't have ice cream i'm
suffering
well any kind of addiction i i'm
assuming
you know like i i've the only addiction
i've really dealt with as far as like
seeing people is like a cigarette
scenario where they're like craving a
cigarette so much and it's like
and it kind of seems like you're kind of
suffering
my contention here is that not having
ice cream
we cannot uh equivocate that you can't
do it
you're suffering i i understand yes
bottom line is let's be careful that we
aren't thinking short term
let's hang on to our sleeping bag let's
carry the extra weight because in the
long run it's going to pay off
yeah that's what i'm getting at that
seems like obvious suffering where
you're like hey i'm gonna need that
tonight
you know i'm gonna literally need that
to stay alive
possibly yeah not the kind where oh
that'd be that'll serve nice tonight
that'll be cool tonight it's not that
i'm gonna need that tonight
or i risk death and yet right now my
suffering is so bad i
gotta get rid of it to not have it
tonight
oh yeah man that is
back to the book now and then if we were
really lucky we'd stop in a village and
command commandeer an abandoned house
for 10 or 20 winks
a korean home had hard adobe mud floors
under which lay an oven the purpose of
which was to provide central heating for
the entire
house of course american soldiers had no
idea how these things worked
and the first time around we built the
biggest fire we could
and went to sleep shivering and bitching
that the gooks didn't know how to do
anything right it turned out though
that the previous occupants of the of
our temporary abode
had the last laugh throughout the night
the floors got hotter and hotter until
some of the guys jackets spontaneously
combusted
and the ammo we made on the floor blew
up snow never looked so good
so you're going one extreme to the other
on most nights
though to stave off the cold we'd
employed the old soldiers
tricks from the bleak frozen days of
valley forge
one was to stuff hay in a poncho and
wrap it so tightly around two guys to
keep in the body heat
another was to fill your steel pot with
coals and embrace it all night long a
practice that continued despite a number
of tired soldiers
who died this way from asphyxiation
another was to put a slug
through your foot in other words shoot
yourself in the foot
i'd thought about that one most of us
did
but it always seemed too risky you might
blow your foot off you might get caught
and court-martialed
but one bitterly cold night when i would
have done anything to get out of that
place i came up with a perfect solution
if i emptied most of the powder out of a
grenade
i could toss it into my foxhole and
blame it on a sneaky [ __ ]
better yet if i chipped the trench on
the side of the foxhole with my bayonet
i could contain the damage to my leg
only
all i'd have to do would be lay my body
in the trench and stick my leg in the
hole tossing a frag grenade and bang
million dollar wound it was a wonderful
idea
somehow a lot better than the one i'd
often saw during a firefight when a guy
would stay in his hole and wave his arms
or kick his legs
like a chorus dancer hoping to catch a
slug and the first boat back to the
states
and i spent all night digging away
working on the trench and thinking how
warm i'd be back in santa monica the war
vet who got it in the leg i chipped and
chipped away on the frozen ground
completely forgetting about the cold the
time the fact that i needed some sleep
or that my buddy who was sleeping
behind sleeping behind the hole may have
had enough
finally it was ready i hoisted myself
into the trench prepared the grenade
and dangled my leg in the hole and i was
just about to pull that pin when i saw
the most beautiful sight
a sight that every infantry man in korea
dreamed of seeing
it was the sun slowly rising it meant
the terrible night was over
it meant i could light my fire and be
warm again
so i forgot my little trench and for a
moment
forgot the other thing the sun meant the
beginning of yet another long day
another step south the never ender
ending
bitter taste of defeat in all our mouths
so this is hack this is freaking
hackworth
who just went awol to go because he
didn't think his troops were fighting
hard enough
he gets to the front lines he's he's is
where he wants to be and he even
hack is thinking about either shooting
himself or
in the foot and then beyond thinking
about he comes up with a scheme with a
grenade
and he actually executes the entire plan
other than the actual
event itself and the only thing that
stops him is that the sun's coming up
that's that's freaking insane yeah
and i'll tell you you know what i take
away from that hold on a little bit
longer the sun's going to come up
hold on a little bit longer the sun's
going to come up i
posted something about that the other
day because
i was watching the sun go down and going
through seal training
when the sun's going down and
you know the instructors will be they
line you up and they say
good night say goodnight to the sun
gents it's going to be a long
cold wet night and they're just making
trying to make
people think hey you got whatever
however many
hours it's going to be dark for 12 8 9
it's going to suck it's going to suck
and that's what they want you to think
about how much it's going to suck but if
in the back of your mind you go yeah sun
will come up in the morning
they can't stop that from happening yeah
to get in that tough situation remember
the sun's gonna come up don't know man
you can get through it man
yeah you got to admit though man i kind
of felt them for a little bit when he's
like digging the thing and
and thinking about how warm he's going
to be it's like
he had his full fantasy outstretched in
front of him yeah
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah and
then i mean it and then it then the
standard starts to get shifted
kind of like oh yeah you're almost kind
of used to like the warmth that you can
imagine you know
and to have that warmth kind of just
taken away meaning you got to shift your
plant back to
like the reality or whatever and i can
see how that could be hard
he's even got the fantasy of like hey
the war vet yeah
yeah you know happy yeah god got hit in
the leg
he's got his whole fantasy planned out
he's ready to execute on this thing
and this guy is like born for
and that's how shitty this situation
gets yeah and that's like
another thing it says like how like
imagine what the other people are
thinking oh yeah imagine what somebody
that doesn't really want to be there
imagine what going through their
freaking minds
you
[Applause]
back to the book and then as if
overnight everything changed
it turned out that despite the fact that
i never saw a general on the battlefield
apparently one lieutenant general
matthew ridgeway
had been all over the in england the
eighth army
front assessing the situation and making
his plans
i wrote in an open jeep he would later
write in his memoirs
and would permit no jeep with the top up
to operate in the combat zone
riding in a closed vehicle in a battle
area puts a man
in the wrong frame of mind it gives him
an erroneous sense of warmth
of safety his mental attitude is that of
an
ostrich poking his head in the sand also
i held the old-fashioned idea that it
helped spirits
of the men to see the old man up there
in the snow and sleet in the mud
sharing the same cold miserable
existence that they had to endure
as a consequence i damn near froze
end quote nevertheless ridgeway
persevered
with no quarter given he banned the word
retreat from the english language at
least insofar as correspondence could
describe our miserable truck to the
south
quote i'm more interested in your plans
for attack
he told a staff officer when the latter
offered up those for another withdrawal
he even he recognized even before we did
that the chinese offensive was running
out of steam
and sought to take advantage of it with
deep patrols to the north to find out
exactly how stretched the enemy was
operation wolfhound was the first of
these
and the fire brigade under the command
of colonel mike alice or mike ellis
one of general ridgway's world war ii
airborne proteges was
on the attack once more so now you have
a totally different situation the guy
goes to the front line and he actually
sees what's happening
and not only does he see what his troops
are going through but he also sees
what's happening with the chinese he
sees them starting to get thinned out he
sees maybe there's not as much pressure
as he originally saw
so he can say look all right we're done
retreating here we go
back to the book two platoons of g
company and elements of the 89th
tank battalion made up one of the task
forces named for and commanded by our
own
company commander jack michael
task force mike lee was given the
mission of taking sue juan
and on the 16th of january it did just
that the enemy was totally unprepared
for the daring daylight assault
george was outside of artillery range
captain mike lee
an old horse caveman approached suwon in
the only way possible
frontally down a road never probed for
mines and fast
my platoon the third was not involved in
the blitzkrieg operation at all but when
the other guys came back having killed
150 enemy without a casualty of their
own
in high spirits and with stories of
captain mike lee sauntering across the
streets of suwon
while enemy machine gun slugs studded
all around him
our morale went sky high we were ready
to take on the world
meanwhile i got my squad and immediately
set about instilling
it with the trust standards and beliefs
about the way things should be done
so so he is now given a squad
because he just showed up there and even
though he's a new guy and even though he
stabbed his own pair of [ __ ] covered
pants
with the bayonet in the middle of the
night he is still giving
a squad so i have to back up a little
bit
so he talks about this trust capital
capital t capital r capital u capital s
capital t
when he first got in the army as i
mentioned
he went to europe when he went to europe
he was not in combat because the war was
over but there was these old timers
there
and he explains i'm gonna
abbreviate a little bit but he kind of
talks about what it was like and where
he developed his
i want to say his personality really and
and you know like i was
i always tell people when you when you
go on the seal teams your first platoon
leaves a big mark on you
and definitely your first two platoons
and the teams have become a lot more
similar than they used to be all the
different seal teams
they're a lot more similar than they
used to be
they used to be they used to have much
more of their own personalities
team one the nickname for team one which
is where i was was
stalag team one because it was
you know you had uniforms inspections
and you had you everyone had short hair
and they inspected your haircuts and all
this stuff
team five was kind of you know they were
kind of wild
kind of just do you know they had no
inspections and they were just kind of
they had the they had the image of being
more
wild then team three was sort of
a little bit in between but they were
also sort of
um they seemed like shy for lack of a
better word like team three was just
kind of like they was doing over there
doing their thing
they were also disconnected because they
were deploying to southwest asia back
then
and team one and team two were deploying
to southeast asia so they were a little
bit
disconnected which made him seem a
little bit more shy i guess i don't know
if that's the right word but they were
just a little bit more
they were all kind of on their own
program team one on one end of the
spectrum stalag team one team five kind
of wild team three somewhere in the
middle
that everyone had their own
personalities and t and the east coast
had their own personalities too
and they kind of lined up a little bit
except for the fact that
team two and team one were sort of the
traditional old school ones
that's why when i went from team one to
the east coast i tried to go to team two
and i did
team four was more like the wild one
team eight was kind of in the middle
that's back in the day now the teams are
very similar because they all kind of
are on the same rotation
you're going the same types of
deployments so they're much more similar
but wherever you spend your early days
leaves an impression on you
and that's kind of what happened to hack
he shows up into this environment
and i'm gonna go into it here back to
the book gradually so now we're going
back in time it's the end of world war
ii the fighting's over but
he's he's deployed and he's in europe
back to the book gradually most of the
world war ii warriors
went back to the states and the post-war
wild west feeling
of lawlessness went too it had been
great fun for a kid to be part of the
hell for leather spirit that made up
the 752nd the 7-5 deuce
but like the tightening of a screw one
turn at a time each day the unit became
more
military the who gives a damn attitude
of the remaining 752 combat leaders and
troopers
replaced by the exacting discipline of
the peacetime
army for the next four years i
learned my trade one year with the recon
company of the tank battalion in the po
valley
and three more months with trieste
united states troops and that's where
the an acronym trust comes from
trieste united states troops the
illustrious unit
whose five thousand hand-picked members
walter winchell called quote the
chrome-plated soldiers of europe
we worked hard during those years long
merciless days of training
repeating training repeating repeating
until we got it right
our transformation into soldiers
inspired and monitored
by those battle savvy ncos
who well knew that discipline and
tactical proficiency on the battlefield
were the direct results of discipline
and combat skills instilled on the
parade
and training grounds at night it was
down on our hands and knees
all of us hand waxing the barracks
floors until we had enough money to chip
in
and buy a buffer you could eat off those
floors
just as you could just as you could
almost be blinded by the brass belt
buckles and brown boots that each of us
wore
polished every night to a dazzling
finish the only way out of these
activities was sick call
but rarely was it used as an excuse it
took as much
effort to see the dock you had to strip
your bed
cram all your perfectly pressed clothes
into a duffel bag see the supply
sergeant and then the first sergeant
not to mention the lion's share of a
month's pay you'd spend having your
clothes repressed when you came back
as it did to continue with the normal
routine punishment was
meted out by a process known as nco
justice i love saying that
for crimes such as a uniform of less
than starched perfection
a bed that didn't bounce a quarter or
even a mildly
insubordinate smirk the sentence could
range from 50
push-ups to double timing around the
parade field holding a 9.5 pound
m1 rifle over your head yelling i'm a
[ __ ] i'm a [ __ ]
until you collapse we rarely saw an
officer above our platoon leader
and he was seldom with the truth because
of administrative duties
but no one seemed too concerned about it
above and below the chain of command it
was well recognized
that as fathers teachers older brothers
and chief tormentors intriesed the nco
corps
had no equal
well that's what he's talking about when
he's talking about this trust attitude
of discipline and training hard that's
where it comes from
so so now we're back to korea we're back
to him getting a squad
and here's what he does meanwhile i got
my squad and immediately set about
instilling
it with my trust standards and beliefs
about the way
things should be done i got out a
notebook and wrote down each man's name
rank and serial number his blood type
weapon number next of kin and whatever
training combat experience he had
i started demanding that rifles be
cleaned and that shoulders shape
up if i saw a soldier walking around
without his weapon the next thing he
knew he'd be on the deck crawling to it
while i stood by kicking him and telling
him that with each kick
was that he was being uh hit with a slug
brutal stuff i'd learned it in basic
training with lieutenant cramer
at the fort knox rifle range kicked my
arm until i positioned it
correctly under my weapon but that's how
a guy learns
besides better my foot and a mythical
slug
than an enemy slug and a goodbye
friendly foot arm or life
that's how a guy learned
you want to talk about a politically
incorrect unpopular thing to say
yeah i remember when i was a new guy
i remember some of the older guys
saying to me you know sometimes people
need to get
beaten so that they learn and you know
what i said
that's correct it's actually accurate
i hate to say it because everyone hates
i don't hate to say it
it's the truth like sometimes
you need to learn a lesson the hard way
and if you don't think it's a big deal
whatever it's a big deal
yeah so
that's what he's saying that's how a guy
learns
once again what do we have we have 18 19
17 21 year old men
who's what is it the frontal cortex what
is it the frontal lobes
they're not free they're not fully
developed yet yeah
they understand physicalness
physicality yeah yeah that's one of
those
things that it's kind of universally
like understood you know pain is not
good
you know yeah some people can take more
pain than others for sure but
after a while it's like we all kind of
don't like pain
of course of course there's weirdos or
whatever but
for the most part they're like these
things that if you start to threaten
it's like you know it's valuable to
people here's the other thing
this is a this is a [ __ ] harsh
environment right
this is war you're getting people ready
for war
you're getting people ready to kill
you're getting people ready to freeze
you're getting people ready to suffer
you're getting people ready to have to
march for miles and miles and miles
with no food with no sleep like
this is what the job entails yeah
and if you think you can pamper someone
and that's going to effectively prepare
them for those type of situations
i don't think that's accurate yeah i
think you're right about that
back to the book my guys thought i was
crazy and a prick
to boot they still didn't believe i paid
my pa
my battlefield dues little did they know
that they were doing the paying in
spades
for making me get that sergeant combat
feeling all over again
then came 6 february which we talked
about on the last podcast
part of another reconnaissance and
forest mission code named operation
thunderbolt which turned into a
full-scale attack and i never got to
complain again
so after his performance which we talked
about on 249 what he did to lead that
day
back to the book in fact the reaction
was the direct opposite
no longer was i the hard ass sergeant
who arrived out of the blue with strange
ideas of discipline and training
now i was just hack hack the great
fighter
who'd gotten shot in the head
courageously saving lives and inflicting
punishment on the enemy
it was a great relief knowing i would
not have to prove myself to anyone
anymore
but what i didn't know at the time was
that the name i made for myself on 6
february 1951
was one i'd have to live up to for the
next 20
years
so he and this is a story that gets
repeated throughout his life
he kind of shows up somewhere he has the
hardcore mentality
people kind of question it but then they
see how it
enables them and and and protects them
in combat
and then they're kind of they're they're
down for the cause
[Music]
back to the book it seemed ironic that
the thing that saved my life on that day
was the very thing i hated most in korea
the cold the
blood kept pumping this is when he's
referring back to when he got shot in
the head
the blood kept pumping but it froze
almost as soon as it came out of my head
after the doc patched me up with the
carlisle bandage
i radioed captain makai michaeli and
gave him a sit rep
i'd already appointed another nco to
skip a little platoon mike lee told me
that
to head for the road be behind which
gilchrist platoon was fighting
he would send a litter jeep there to
pick me up the platoon dock
always worried about his flock wanted to
tag along i told him i'd make it
policed up one of our deads m1s and
headed off
i kept low using the rice paddy walls
and irrigation ditches for cover
i probably wouldn't have felt it if i'd
gotten hit again anyways because during
my run back down the drainage ditch
i'd fallen through the ice and been
soaked from the waist down
the water and zero degree weather turned
my lower tr
my lower torso into a block of ice my
head was spinning
and my balls were frozen and i wasn't
sure which one worried me more
then i came upon pfc charles the guy had
earlier tasked
to take the two north korean pows we
captured during that morning
to the old man for interrogation charles
was sitting in a drainage ditch by the
road
eating a can of sea rations at his feet
were the prisoners
stretched out in the ditch dead each
from a single bullet in the back of the
head
i was outraged why'd you kill them
they tried to escape he said simply but
i didn't believe him
besides he continued i wasn't going to
risk my ass to get two
gooks out of here there wasn't much i
could do
i told him to report back to the platoon
gilchrist
later told me that charles had received
word
only days before that his brother had
been killed in action over in the second
division
not too good a choice for an escort hack
he'd remark
drawing on his pipe i continued on
small arms and machine gun fire was
skipping down the road
i gave it all a big miss and kept to my
little ditch i headed south until i met
lieutenant colonel
gordon murch our old battalion co
who was controlling the battle from his
tactical cp behind a roadside
knoll a few hundred yards from the front
there i was placed on a litter
in a medical jeep and as we bumped down
the road all i could think was
hallelujah
hallelujah got it made i'm leaving this
goddamn
place or so i thought
because just then the jeep's radio
crackled on first platoon george company
got a serious wound real bad
get there fast he'll be on the side of
the road
i couldn't believe it let me out i'll
wait here so there's
he's getting out of there on this jeep
and all of a sudden over the radio says
hey we need that jeep back here
and hack we're saying let me out bro let
me out
i'll wait here i thought but i was too
weak too tired too cold
to get the words out the jeep spun
around and headed back up that fire
swept road
past colonel merch right into the jaws
the whole goddamn communist army
we stopped the medics calmly sauntered
out to pick up the other casualty
they took all the time in the world or
so it seemed while the enemy used the
large red cross markings on the jeep for
target practice
the jeep's canvas size sides were being
ventilated
the slugs were passing above and below
my litter i felt totally helpless
and swore that whoever the wounded guy
was i would hate him for life
which from the way things were going was
not going to be long
it turned out he was a buddy through the
hawaiian mafia connection
a handsome six-footer named ray mendez
i almost kept my kept to my word though
when i found out
his critical wound to be a slug in the
thigh when he'd been hit he'd rolled up
in a ball
blood had squirted out of his leg all
over the front of his jacket and someone
had concluded
that he had taken it in the gut
oblivious to the fight raging on all
sides of our thin-skinned ambulance
jeep mendez became chirpier and chirpier
as we headed out of the battle area
he sang praises of his million dollar
wound and spun dreams about his in
imminent return to the islands me one
big war hero brah
he said the regimental collection
collecting station was jammed with
casualties the surgeon who bent over my
litter was covered with blood
like a butcher we're going to bypass
division clearing and send you straight
to mash at sioux one he said
you're on your way home the next stop
was quick
mash was near the emergency runway at
sue juan
the doc there wrote on my wounded leg oh
my wounded tag
emergency air evac which somehow scared
me
and before i knew it i was strapped down
to the deck of a c-47
we took off just at dark
why don't they close the goddamn door i
thought
it had to be open because it i'd never
been colder
i was shaking like a jackhammer i
couldn't feel my hands or feet
a flight nurse stayed right with me
another anonymous son
ominous sign so he's getting like they
put airy back immediately he's like oh
god that means i must be really wounded
bad he's got this flight nurse staying
right with him
she piled on blanket after blanket with
no effect just as i was reaching the
point where i didn't know if i could
take it anymore we landed in busan
and it was another world paradise in
fact
a heated ambulance was waiting as they
loaded me in
i felt like that old bull weevil who
lived in the red hot fire
mighty warm but nice i'd found a home
i fell asleep and didn't wake up again
until i was being winched aboard the
hospital ship
uss haven in busan harbor
i opened my eyes and everything i saw
was white
clean and oh so warm
medics were starched the nurses all
looked like doris day
i was stripped placed in crisp white
sheets
with soft blue blankets i was safe and
suddenly starving
a medic came down to the immediate
rescue with a delicious hot meal
i wolfed it down just in time for the
next wonder of wonders a beautiful young
nurse
in a tight little white outfit who came
to clean me up
why didn't i join the navy i thought
except for my bath in the korean tub i
hadn't washed in more than two months
i was caked with dry blood korean mud
and god only knew what else
each time the nurse scraped off one
filthy layer she'd have to change the
sheets and start again
it took four sheet changes with no help
from me because
as a head wound i wasn't allowed to move
at all
next the poor girl had to shave off my
ratty beard
bad hygiene and ingrown hairs had
covered my face with
boil-like pimples it was too terrible to
be funny
watching the nurse bobbing and weaving
all over the place to avoid flying
debris every time that razor
hit one of the anti-personnel mines
buried in my cheeks
the next few days were a haze sleep
really hard sleep
people standing over me having whispered
consultations
blood iv x-ray after x-ray doctors
probing asking questions how many
fingers do you see
i slowly regained my strength someone
somebody commandeered my waltham watch
i never saw it again the sleep was good
i caught up on months of it lost
but then i started getting restless
the ward though spotlessly clean and
staffed with talented delegated
dedicated pros was an extremely
depressing place
we were all head wounds most either
terminal
or vegetable cases
it was amazing that many it was amazing
that many
young boys all of them were still
sucking in air
one guy had tubes running out of
everywhere he'd caught a slug right
between the eyes
i wanted out i'd had my little vacation
i told the docs i'm ready to return to
my platoon there's nothing wrong with me
the doctors probably thought that the
bullet had done some pretty serious
damage to my brain
nobody wanted to go back to the front
they didn't realize that the guys in
third platoon
were my brothers my family and i loved
them
i'd only been with them three weeks it
was true
but in combat that's a lifetime and i
didn't want to leave them
out there alone if by being there
i could help keep them alive keep them
out of a head wound ward
i want to go back i kept telling them
well
he did go back he healed up
he healed up pretty quickly and
went back to his platoon by mid-march
so he was out for maybe a month and a
half
and
you know this book is just
incredibly good by the way that's page
69 of an 800 page book that's where
we're at
page 69 of an 800 page book just
in korea he's gonna get two more purple
hearts
going to get battlefield commissioned
he's going to take command of a new
raider unit
he's going to go on offense against the
enemy he's going to get awarded
three silver stars
then he's going to go back to america
he's going to volunteer for
another tour
with the 40th infantry division
and then that war is going to end and
he's going to stay in the army
and he's going to go through all the
political things that you have to go
through to move up the chain of command
and then he's going to eventually deploy
to vietnam
as a battalion operations officer as a
battalion commander
he's going to go there with uh with sla
marshall
and then he's going to go and he's going
to be a battalion commander for the
439th
infantry and eventually
he conducts his
his famous or his infamous interview
depending on how you look at it with the
issues and answers where he
disparages a lot of the senior army and
a lot of the
civilian leadership
after which he is drummed out of the
army
rapidly and all the i mean these events
that take place they're all
documented with such detail
and it just gives so much information
about leadership about human nature
about the way people act about why
people do what they do
[Applause]
there's so much to learn from this book
so we're almost at two hours right now
uh what an honor it was
for me to have written the forward to
this thing this book that had such a
huge impact on me
check it out check out the book one
thing that's cool about it
is you don't have to look it's 800 pages
long
you don't have to read the whole book in
one sitting
you know the story i just told you the
story the story is about a guy that's
that's that freaking loves his troops
throughout his career
and you pick it up anywhere and you read
what he's going through for two or three
pages
i guarantee you'll get a lesson out of
it it's it's that good and you don't
have
you don't have to read the whole thing
at once you will you'll want to
because you'll want to know what's going
to happen like i said
we we're on page 69 right now and by the
way we skipped a bunch i skipped a whole
section
because he he kind of talks about the
the opening
action scene that i talked about but
then he kind of goes into how he ended
up in the army and goes through the
world war ii and he goes through the
trust troops and all that
then he picks back up with korea so we
didn't even cover we probably covered 40
pages out of a 800 page book
so check out the book
it will teach you valuable leadership
lessons and it will teach you how to
become
smarter as leader and it will teach you
how to become
a better person about face colonel david
hackworth
speaking of being better echo charles
yes sir
do you have any let's say
recommendations
sure recommendations well actually back
to the hawaiian guy
me one big war hero bro yeah it's not
me he didn't say me what do you say i
because in pidgin no well yeah i'm sure
hacksworth i'm sure hackworth
maybe remembered it incorrectly
hackworth was wrong is what i'm hearing
okay i'm just saying
in pidgin you don't say me i might have
read it wrong
no that's what he says yeah he says me
one big war hero bro
yeah so he'd be using an incorrect
pigeon i won big
war hero okay
also it kind of reminded me like
this just totally never thought about
this but when i when
i'm realizing in pigeon you say one
instead of
a like ah like hey toss me a beer and
whatever toss me one beer
one beer yeah it's weird it's like a
subtle difference right there
i won beer no not no no i say i
like fry but one is like you know like
in
non-pigeon we'll say for like a better
term
you say one as it only when
the option of more than one is
considered in the scenario
you know but in pidgin you just say one
just means a whether
two or more or whatever is considered or
not got it
it's insane toss me one beer bro
i won big war hero as opposed to i'm two
big war heroes they see what i'm saying
i want to be i'm a big war
you see you see the translation right
i'm glad that's
why you're here man
if need be yes yes all right so okay
becoming better so i was thinking about
this the other day
you know my neighbors are over and they
ask hey do you work out every day
i was like yeah well i tried to you know
the whole deal
you work out every day right jocko yes
every day like seven days a week
i mean that's kind of the the plan
here's the deal uh
i will try and work out every single day
sometimes
you have a travel day you know the
flight's at 6 15
i got to bed at 11. do i am i going to
get up at 3 15
or or no even earlier than that 3
no my body could probably use the extra
sleep more than it could use the workout
yeah
exactly but i know that there are days
like that out there
so therefore i don't voluntarily take
days off
yeah yeah so
and kind yeah i dig it same deal
more or less you know um but why like
why do you work out every day
i'm not saying you shouldn't i'm just
saying you ever think about like why do
you work out every day
you know and then like how do you work
out every day like what
like why why i work out every day so i
can stay in shape bro
yeah but you don't have to work out
every day to stay in shape okay i think
well there has to be more to it than
that i think it's good for you
mentally and physically there you go
mentally
right mentally that's so that's such a
broad thing to say though
too and i mean that in a good way i
don't mean it like
whoa those are copper i'm not saying
that i'm saying like that's yeah
mentally
man it's a big deal mentally where
that's part of like essentially like
your life
you know it's part of like who you are
yeah you know like that's the discipline
yeah and there's a lot of things like
that but
they seem like real small because so
many people do it
you know how like you know some people
they they make their bed every single
day
right there's that and then there's like
okay then you get all the way down the
spectrum like obvious things like oh i
brush my teeth every day or whatever
yeah you know
but man you're essentially if you want
to call it the path
like working out every day beyond the
physical
benefits and you know whatever being
stronger whatever
working out every day is like
it's one of those things where if you
can adjust your standard to that
in that way that's a good thing that it
that'll
yeah that'll keep you that'll keep you
in a place that's like
i guess that's why we call it the path
it'll keep you on the path yeah i think
that developing a pattern
is very positive right so sticking to
the pattern
yeah once you deviate let's face it
you lose momentum and that's a good way
to develop a pattern as far as staying
in shape working out because let's face
it like working out a lot of times like
we can
consider that as like kind of low on the
priority list for a lot of reasons
and i understand but if you're told
thing
is like no i work out every day the same
way i freaking
brush like brush my teeth every day you
know it's like part of the day
i floss my teeth every day yeah yeah so
it's like one of those things
that started when i joined the navy what
flossie they said floss your teeth every
day i was like okay
and i started doing it every day
cool man yeah see and that's good it's
the reason i laugh is because it's funny
how it's like that simple for you yeah
you know
like it's like the dentist tells you to
floss oh yeah you get told that your
whole life but then they're like
okay they say hey floss your teeth every
day okay roger that
so yeah hey how about this workout every
day every single day it's a good move
well but it is a good way to get i feel
like there's some place where you're
going with this i feel like this is a
building up to some statement
yeah and here's it's not building up to
statement it's kind of wrong that's kind
of a big letdown
[Laughter]
because i was thinking you had some kind
of philosophical
eureka moment yeah i mean but basically
what you're saying is work out every day
i have a headache it'll take you that
long to say it it's kind of making me
wonder
i'm telling you why you should work out
every day because let's face it like if
you just say hey work out every day
there's a lot of pushback you can get
like no you need rest days no you need
you know
like there's a there's you know there's
a big philosophy to it
but working out every day just like how
you said which i'm glad you did by the
way
it's it's a it's a mental thing yes
and of course physical but that's
obvious yeah it's a mental thing so
and then you additionally you said to
you know make it a
what a routine or whatever like it's
just part of your day develop a pattern
develop a pattern yes exactly right
that's a good way to develop the pattern
is you just automatically
assume and do it every day just
automatically that's part of the day
you know not like oh i'm gonna try to
get a workout in today
you know it's not that it's like that's
it's more of a given you know kind of
thing
it's a weird thing that i'll say to
people be like how do you die
that's yeah sure yeah or like what do
you say to yourself i don't say anything
yeah i don't even
it's a weird thing to say i don't even
think about it yeah i don't sit there
and be like
wow you know i have worked out for five
days straight so
i really probably don't actually need to
work out today
i could use you know what's like you
know i actually read once four years ago
in a muslim fitness magazine that
you know five days in a row is a bit too
much to work out you should take that
whatever day off
you always can find 80 million ways to
rationalize
you know the bulgarians actually on
their periodization cycle they only
you know like there's a million
different i was reading about michael
phelps and even though he trained
hard there was always one day a week
that he would just rest like
everyone's got a million different
rationalizing things that you can put in
your head
yeah yeah even though they're you should
get that's that's
the rationalizing thing there's a
there's a tv show
that uh it's called alone
and it's tv show called alone they put
people out in the wilderness i heard
about it on joe rogan
because he had one of the winners on the
show
and i didn't even hear that i just heard
joe rogan mention it he was like
yeah the show was crazy they put them
out and so i was with my wife and my
youngest daughter
and they were looking for something to
watch and i go
i go well hey there's a show called
alone it's about being alone in the
wilderness
long story short everyone quits
and you you the show goes on until only
one person
is left everyone else quits so
they're in different places they're
alone in the wilderness
okay they're alone in the wilderness oh
with each other though no
they're alone isolated alone so as you
watch this
you see people and they're they have
cameras with them so they're talking to
themselves
and it's been funny to watch
because you can see people when they're
gonna quit yeah and you're like oh
they're rational
so now now i've got my youngest daughter
who's 11
when someone starts rationalizing she
says
oh he's rationalizing because you know
someone will say
you know i could stay out here for a
long time but you know i really miss my
family
yeah yeah and you're like oh he's
rationalizing or or
i just don't know if it's worth you know
what this is doing to my body i've done
some stuff to start stuff to my body and
i'm starting to think about even though
the money would be nice but
so we start rationalizing and the reason
i mean you'd see that
in zeal training in seal training you'd
see someone say
you know i don't know if you know i'm
i'm actually probably gonna get married
and i don't know if it's the right thing
to do to put my
girlfriend through this and you're like
okay
yeah yeah but for sure definitely don't
want to put your wife through this
yeah go quit yeah go quit that's so true
so it's so easy to rationalize things
rationalization is the enemy and that
brings me back to where i started this
which was i'm not thinking about it
because i know that my i know that my
rationalization my powers of
rationalization can
can win oh yeah i can convince myself 48
times
i just quoted a muscle and fitness
magazine from 1987
that said that the bulgarians ensure
that they get at least one complete day
of rest for every five days of working
out
you can support any crap that you want
to support
if you just if you just want to
rationalize with yourself be irrational
be irrational shut up
do what you're supposed to do
yeah that uh rationalizing
is i'm very successful
person in regards to rationalism
everyone is tough
everyone is yeah you also know your own
you know
what to say you know how to like you're
into being
uh healthy right you're like yeah you
know i did see that
i did what just watched that youtube
video and they talked about the value of
rest and it
actually is more important it's actually
more important than diet and lifting
the most important thing is rest and i
think i've been really
i don't think i think i think i actually
in order to truly have discipline
i need to have the discipline just to
not work out today that's gonna take
discipline
these are all lies they're all just lies
they're all just rationalization i i
like today
i was lifting today hell yeah but
i was rationalizing prior to lifting i
was rationalizing
i'm sitting there like observing myself
rationalizing
and what i had to do was actually i i
was feeling a little tweak
in my leg in my knee no very minor
but i was like well you know maybe you
know just let that thing heal up don't
want it and
it's like no actually shut up yeah and i
i
lift it lighter yeah but
i didn't rationalize yeah i was like
okay cool but hurt leg good
you know it's like stretching yeah calm
thing to combat
rationalizing and i will all just shut
up and do what you're supposed to do
that's one thing
yeah yeah yeah for sure but
what i do or sometimes if have the
strength
uh is all imagine like you know how like
it all come with you with an issue like
a
an excuse or something and you always
have some work around
for the excuse every single time like
somewhere and it's like man
if you can just imagine kind of what
jaco would say
right now you know because you could
legitimately have a tweak in your knee
yeah you could and in varying levels it
could be like almost like hey if you
start doing this squat routine that you
have planned like you
will make it worse for sure you know but
you can also just use your other leg
yeah some other pistols oh yeah some
other stuff how about that how's that
sound
oh yeah and a lot of times like that
other stuff is like man i'd rather
battle through the pain to be honest
okay so when you go surfing sometimes
it's like cold
miserable maybe the waves aren't that
great but you know you should go
so stoner and i we had this rule for a
little while
when we got to our surf spot we could
either go surfing
or if you don't want to go surfing
that's fine but now you have to swim
around the pier
[Laughter]
so it's like that's the deal so guess
what you do you go surfing and you know
you should go surfing anyways even if
you get two good waves
it's worth it and you got to work out
you know you got to paddle
but you're either going to so you should
have an alternative
like hey you can either work out today
or
you can whatever whatever some miserable
thing is that sucks worse than working
out
yeah right yeah i'm gonna come up with
that thing
yeah so and actually i actually do that
but it's still working out so it's like
a
version of that it's it's a perfect uh
uh
it's analogous to your surfing thing
it's either do the workout plan
yeah or do this metcon it's a specific
metcon there's two of them
if i did this one the the last time i
did metcon i'd do this other one that's
it they're just two
so it's like either do the full workout
or do the metcon so if it's like man
if you're if you think your knee is
tweaked or whatever you can do the mech
that's cool yeah there you go and it's
like
it's right on the borderline of the
workout and the metcon suck the same
yeah equally yeah but you know how
sometimes you're just not in the mood to
to do that workout yeah and then
sometimes you're really not even going
to do the metcons
it's weird how sometimes you want to do
sometimes you would prefer to do
a metcon and sometimes you would prefer
to lift heavy
right it's okay it's okay what's not
okay is
i don't feel like lifting heavy so i'm
just not gonna do anything before i
don't feel like doing a metcon so i'm
just
not gonna do anything yeah exactly what
you wanna do i like that i like that
option you can either do this or that
and i i do that to a certain level
you know if i if i just whatever i don't
feel like doing
anything that's going to be a metcon
scenario i'll be cool
i'm going to lift heavy you know and i'm
going to grind it out too
it's not like i'm gonna say oh well i'm
just gonna you know yeah no i'm gonna
get some
that's why i like the metc because the
metcon is very specific like you either
did it or you just didn't do it
correctly you know kind of thing like it
has the
the rest in between each it's basically
circuit training yeah
essentially and i got to do a certain
weight a certain amount
of reps per thing and so it's there it's
not like oh i'm going to go light
or i'm going to slack it's kind of hard
to slack because it's like real glaring
if you do
so yeah you're choosing one or the other
i don't care what you're in the mood for
or not in the mood for like you gotta do
one you know
but if so i always have that in play
always
yeah and it works yeah it's good to give
yourself a shitty alternative
[Laughter]
yes yes sir it is in these cases for
sure
yeah well anyway hopefully
we are on the path whether you're
working out every day or not i
i'd say i recommend work out every day
here's the thing if you're
hurting yourself or something like that
don't do that workout yeah yeah for sure
don't do something that's going to
injure you yeah
but don't do nothing don't do nothing do
a very deliberate
yeah workout every day and the point is
there too is like that it
after a while it does just become normal
yeah like
just like making coffee or may you know
like every day it's just oh that's sort
of
just what you do every single day it's
like right it becomes that you know
and boom you're a new person boom just
like that just like that
anyway we're all in the path we're
working on it every day hey look your
joints get sore i get it
right my knees are actually sore
actually sore
but i did squat super hard the other day
you know the kind where mentally you go
into like
getting yeah or wraps or whatever
in squats too and so mentally you kind
of it's almost like a
you turn off a certain part of your mind
you know so and you're just
your body just has to like basically
facilitate the rest
but then when you're done when your mind
switches back on you're like
just in pain you know how you got to
basically pay the price mentally
afterwards
you're on the road to recovery which is
cool but anyway it was one of those
scenarios
and yeah my knees were weird strangely
sore on the inside i don't know oddly
it's
fully healed now too by the way that was
two days ago
nonetheless point is sometimes your
joints get sore mine too chocolates too
when you get older
we're all getting older i know no matter
how old you are nah
we're not getting older no but like
everyone goes oh it's because you're
getting older no
because you're not taking care you're
taking care less yeah and also
like when i was younger you have sore
yeah is that worse yeah mine's not
really worse
i feel like my capacity maybe my
enthusiasm sometimes is less
but that might be just because i got
more stuff going on as an adult you see
what i'm saying
i don't know nonetheless if your joints
are sore don't worry when did you become
an adult
how old were you i want to say like mid
30s
i think it was mid never to be honest
with you but
i don't know i think it's a slowly slow
gradual we're still heading there
yeah we're working hard kids kids kids
move that forward when you have kids you
start to become an adult pretty quickly
yeah yeah yeah certain elements
yeah i mean you've got like humans that
now rely on you for your
food for their food yeah so kind of for
everything and everything else yeah like
roof yeah like and health
[Music]
bunch of things we're talking about yeah
that can switch on the adult circuits
for sure for sure how would you how
would your oldest seven
yeah so i was probably right probably
mid 30s you started kind of
moving in the direction of yeah i think
so too
nonetheless i don't have sword joints
at the moment and that is because what i
was trying to tell
our everyone the people are people
jacques supplementation called jocko
fuel the joint stuff is joint warfare
there is also super krill oil which has
other health
benefits by the way but anyway in
combination this will keep your joints
in the game working out seven days a
week working out five days a week
whatever working out nine days a week
all of that stuff these will keep them
together
the whole time you're gonna be worried
about your gains not your joints
dang check them out i'm just saying that
hey also vitamin d uh now
we're in the midst of the pandemic
and everybody is saying take vitamin d
thankfully
we make vitamin d vitamin d3 get some of
that you can also get
cold war which is immune health
which again these are products that
we've had and
it's pretty cool that a lot of people
are recommending them
right now so you can stay healthy
and then on top of all this working out
that you're doing you're probably gonna
need some
what echo likes to call additional
protein
yes additional well because
you know there's a debate if you will
depending on your lifestyle
of how much protein you should have you
see what i'm saying
so if you want to supplement protein
iron
how many people are listening to this
right now uh yeah
zero yeah you know
nonetheless it doesn't even matter it
doesn't matter because for those six
people they're getting
ready they're gonna hear fire yes
exactly they're gonna hear fire as far
as fire goes yes
nonetheless if you're going to
supplement protein you might as well
have another form of dessert that's
what smoke is i know strange name i get
it
nonetheless supplement your protein like
a dessert
do it that way you got some kids protein
too warrior kid protein
because why would you feed your kids
something that's actual poison you
wouldn't do it you'd get them more your
kid molk
they will love it you will love that
they're having it
they will be healthier stronger smarter
better they're gonna have
a massive deadlift for sure just 100
uh white tea we got that and we also got
these cans of
what we call discipline go is it an
energy drink
you know what it is because it gives you
energy but it gives you
real energy not if not a lie
not just a not just a massive hit of
caffeine
300 milligrams of caffeine look you you
inject 300
milligrams of caffeine into a piece of
wood and it starts to get exciting
but after a little while it's like very
quickly it's back to just being wood you
put a bunch of sugar into
a into a rat and it gets all excited
that's fake energy
there's a real energy it's got it's not
got no sugar in it but it still tastes
good it's sweet with my food
yeah well here's the thing the blah blah
and i get it
i i understand why you said blah blah
blah because it's like yeah these are
all these numbers and
all this stuff whatever but man i kind
of looked into it i did look into it by
the way
and so so preservatives sweeteners
like these things these are the things
that make normal
energy drinks yeah bad for you yeah yeah
the ones that are bad for you and you
know there's a bunch of energy drinks so
i can't eat so it's hard to for me in
the spirit of accuracy to say
oh all energy drinks or all this or all
that
but the preservatives and artificial
sweeteners are
are straight up poison
straight up but they do sweeten or they
do preserve or do it you know and
there's this little these list of very
specific things that they put in
the only reason they're in there is not
to help you yes
to help the drink it helps them
in order to not put chemicals in there
to preserve it
we pasteurize it like what you do with
milk
yes so and in order to sweeten it we've
only got monk fruit which
is good for you monk fruit is good for
you yeah so
anyways all these different items uh you
can get it you can get origin maine.com
you can also get them at the vitamin
shop and
we're a little we're about to enter a
new market
in the world you know when people say oh
i really wish this stuff was available
here or there we're moving in that
direction
it's starting started with vitamin shop
next thing we're going into is a place
called wawa
which is a convenience store mostly east
coast
we're starting in florida and virginia
if you live in those areas be on the
lookout because you'll be able to walk
into a wawa
and clean out the shelf
clean out the shelf get yourself some
discipline go try the different flavors
and yeah you'll get that little you'll
get that little
mid-morning hater
and you won't get a post-drink crash
were you like
yeah no yeah and and being in the
in the store is like especially like a
convenience store scenario whatever it
makes it does
this is a big deal in this sense where
right now and i get it like you you
order your shipment you know you get it
whether it be online or whatever
um or find a vitamin shop for sure but
when it's when it's at the store you can
just sort of stop
in and get one kind of thing on the way
here on the way there or whatever
it makes it a whole different process
yeah way more convenient if you were
probably why they call it convenience
stores
by the way yeah unless that's a good
that's good news right there
uh yeah so discipline go is what it's
called in the can i don't know if you
mentioned that for those who may not
have known that got it
thank you so anyway yes uh or origin
mean
dot com yeah you can get it there also
other stuff at origin main is
jiu-jitsu if you don't have one get one
from there american-made oh good
what are we doing without a jiu-jitsu at
this point i have no idea we should
definitely be having a jiu-jitsu
yes sir that's for sure also jeans
american
denim also some hoodies some other
clothing items on there american-made
boots
works of art i've heard them be referred
to as
works of art made in america oh you just
made pete roberts
so happy well it's accurate i agree with
the statement
yeah they are this is works of art and
also
the preservation of a culture
of creation and manufacturing
that's what's happening this is a loss
this is a
dying art a dying
capability that is now being preserved
whether it's the the manufacturing of
the
cloth to make the geese whether it's the
manufacturing of the boots
whether it's the the sewing and
fabrication of the jeans all of it
is a preservation of a manufacturing
manufacturing thread
that ties america together so
we're not going to let it die by the way
and we appreciate you all
helping us keep it alive so yes origin
main
dot com that's where you can get this
stuff also jacquard has a story jackal
story
i just made like kind of a a statement
and then you go yeah so you know
that's where you can get this stuff but
it's true okay there you go i'm sorry
i'm sorry
man that was so freaking deep bro it was
deep
and man thank you so much for for saying
that you're welcome
you're welcome anyway john i'm glad that
my services have been
fully dot com epic my speech was
yes sir it was javascript.com we
we can get our shirts this one equals
freedom
deathcore to the core by the way good
good get out all these [ __ ] you if you
want to represent while you're on the
path jocklestort.com to the book
back to the book all day that's a shirt
oh yeah also hoodies on there
some tank tops other other items
so we're adding we got a hardcore
recondos on there back in stock
by the way yeah yeah speaking of david
and we didn't even get to this part of
about face oh well
but i think we all know that the the the
what he called the legend or the what do
you call it when
everyone's sorted the cannon is that
what it's called the cannon is like
a big book or a big work of art i mean a
big workup right
the part of the story that's like you
know
they became the crux of the story
perhaps no
it's it's like legendary a legendary
kind of comic part of the story like one
of them
yeah yeah anyway why they're called
called
the hardcore rather than the hopeless
yeah
hardcore condos yes sir no slack um
yes so we got that shirt we got we got
some cool stuff continuously adding
items on there maybe like once a month
month once every two months maybe so
anyway check in
there if you like we do have an email
list if you want to get emailed
for new stuff um basically just new
stuff that's it
pretty much were your kids soaps on
there too yes sir
which is legit yes that's all we use now
and here's
here you know what's weird the um the
compliments
that i hear personally and online is
that it smells
real good there you go it doesn't seem
like that was like one of the things
that we're
or that ate in and then we're like
trying to like push just the byproduct
of excellence
yeah yeah and that is the case for sure
yes even though it smells good which i
agree with but even more important
it can help you it can help your family
stay clean stay clean subscribe to the
podcast
don't just subscribe to this podcast we
got some other podcasts we got the jocko
unraveling podcast we got the grounded
podcast we got the warrior kid podcast
we got a youtube channel
if you want to see echo's youtube uh uh
videos that he makes where he makes
everything
explode and blow up and catch on fire
except if it's a long video in which
case i'll just let you be bored with
that
which he's fine with we got an album
called psychological warfare
which is me talking about moments of
weakness that that we
may need to overcome you might need a
little help overcoming that
when you try to rationalize you might be
trying to rationalize we can fight
through that together
press play you press play you have it on
there you have a little
mp3 on there you press play on your
phone
that's true and then all of a sudden you
stop rationalizing and you start
doing uh flip side canvas
if you want to not rationalize visually
get yourself some get yourself some
things to
represent i know that leif just told me
that he hooked up the
echelon front hq building in
texas with some flip side canvas
works for the walls uh
we also have some books hey first of all
this book right here about face
written by colonel david hackworth i
wrote the foreword
what an honor check it out this is a
book you can refer back to
forever i'm still reading it i have been
reading this book
for approximately
i would say approximately 20 years
approximately 20 years and i'm still
reading it
we also have the code the evaluation the
protocol written by myself
dave burke sarah armstrong in the mix on
that one
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual all the answers are in there
all the answers are in there they really
are get that book you can look up oh you
got a problem with your employees act in
a certain way
cool go to leadership strategy oh your
boss you're having a hard time leading
up the channel good cool go in there
check it out oh your morale is down for
your troops okay go in there check it
out
all the answers are in there leadership
strategy and tactics field manual we got
way of the warrior kid one two
three we got four on the way be checking
out for it we'll have it to pre-order
as asap it's uh
it's it's the final version
is with the printers at this time oh
okay yeah so we're there yeah
we also want to know you know sometimes
we
collectively cause shortages of certain
books so if you want to get way the
warrior kid 4
please pre-order it so that you don't
get caught
at christmas time with no book for your
little warrior kid
don't forget about mikey and the dragons
speaking of warrior kids don't forget
about the discipline equals freedom
field manual there is a new edition out
the new addition
i wrote a bunch more for it we added it
in there
it's got a new cover it's got a
photograph by echo charles on the cover
the photograph is of my head
which we which you took of me yes you
think that there
was there a big like setting up of the
lighting and all this stuff
no i was standing in echo charles's
hallway we just got done recording the
podcast in his living room
and he goes hold on a second turn around
and he's holding a camera and he goes
click click and one of those two shots
is echo's iconic picture
that is on the cover it's bigger have i
shown you the new one yet i have one
you have the it's not a completed one
it's actually
oh you have a fake link on the inside
okay i have the cover
i'll bring you the real one yeah i'll
bring the real one so they made it look
a little bit more
and you know i'm i'm an old school
hardcore kid from
and so things had a certain look to them
and this one kind of moved in that
direction a little bit being a little
bit
like my old school hardcore days diy
make things happen you got a good track
record with covers like i say
yeah yeah they look solid well thank you
i appreciate it
so there's all those books plus there's
extreme ownership plus the dichotomy of
leadership
which i wrote with my brother leif babin
we have echelon front which is a
leadership consultancy we've solved
problems through leadership that's what
we do go to echelonfront.com
if you need help in your business we
have ef online
where we are providing leadership
instruction
through an online platform answering
questions
there's a forum there's all kinds of
things to do on there there's courses to
take
there is ef overwatch where we are
taking people from the military
and putting them into civilian companies
in leadership positions people that
understand the principles that we talk
about here
and finally if you want to help
if you want to help out our military
members active members retired members
their families gold star families if you
want to
support then check out mark lee's
mom that's mark lee from tasking to
bruiser
his mom mama lee she has a charity
organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to
americasmightywarriors.org
and if you if you feel the need
if you just feel the need to hear more
of my unbearable bellowing
or you maybe you just need a little
hitter a little dose of echoes
muddled meanderings which we certainly
got plenty of today
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on
instagram which echo just so he knows
what i'm talking about he refers to
instagram
as the gram
facebook echo is at echo charles and i
am at jocko willink and
thanks once again to my mentor
colonel david hackworth for everything
he did for me
for his soldiers for the army and for
america and thanks to all the military
personnel
out there right now right now
right at this moment while you're
sitting there
listening to this podcast while we're
sitting here making this podcast
there are military personnel out there
right now
holding the line against evil
and protecting our way of life
and the same thing to police and law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and emts and dispatchers and
correctional officers
border patrol secret service all other
first responders
thank you for holding the line and
protecting us
here at home
and everyone else out there
you know we have to remember that
in life most of the time
we don't have the luxury
we don't have the luxury of a colonel or
a captain or a lieutenant or a sergeant
hackworth
in our lives we don't have
someone there to keep us in line to make
us
do push-ups and give us a good
swift kick in the ass when we slack off
what we have to do is we have to be our
own
sergeant hackworth we have to be our own
mr infantry we have to be our own
hardcore recondo to hold
the highest standards and allow
no [ __ ] slack
that is our charge as leaders
as people as human beings
so go out there
and get after it
until next time this is echo
and jocko out